um oje.
Consiguiron.
Legal já teve. André ali? Já tentou aplicar alguma coisa?
Acordei querendo mudar de empresa.
Isso acontece. Quase nunca acontece. Só toda hora.
Eu também custei para dormir. Em relação à transcrição de ontem. Está disponível em alguma plataforma? A transcrição está dentro Do Repositório Lá Dentro Da Pasta Transcripts.
Estou em dúvida de como diferenciar a camada de ontologia da camada semântica. Rafa, quer falar um pouquinho sobre essa diferença?
Para os dois propósitos diferentes.
Qual foi a pergunta? Foi mal. Estava prestando atenção numa outra coisa. Aqui.
Yeah, foi mal. Qual a diferença de uma camada de ontologia para uma camada semântica?
A semântica vai dar um sentido para. Para.
Aquilo que você está Trabalhando Então Por Exemplo Se Você Tem Uma Tabela De Vendas Você Trabalha Com O Sentido de falar. O que ela quer dizer? Então a gente tem naquela tabela registros relacionados à venda, onde você vai ter provavelmente dados de.
Produtos que foram vendidos, pessoas que compraram. Então e como elas se relacionam? Então, a semântica? Ela vai te dar uma tradução.
Significado. A ontologia, não, a ontologia vai te mostrar como é que a gente vincula uma entidade a outra.
Então, se você tem uma tabela de vendas, ela vai te mostrar como é que funciona a relação entre vendas E Produtos Então Uma Venda Ela Pode Ter Vários Produtos Ela Pertence A Um Cliente Então Ela Vai Te Mostrar Correlação.
Ontológica em cima disso. Então, ontologia, na verdade é muito mais ampla que a semântica, porque a semântica, você consegue fazer uma tradução.
Para termos de linguagem natural. Vamos dizer assim. Em termos bem simples, já a ontologia não. Ela vai criar um.
Uma estrutura em volta da sua. Do seu dado, onde você consegue não somente fazer identificação de domínios de negócio, Como Por Exemplo Criar Corrimões De Validação Como Você Consegue.
Dar o seu dado. Então, por exemplo, eles falam muito sobre colocar dados ontológicos dentro do Ledger, para você fechar Regra De Negócio Dentro De Um Agente Então A Ideia é Que Você Tenha Uma Camada De Agente Muito Fina E.
O dado ontológico. Venha ali dentro do leve para que a gente consiga fazer o fechamento dessa informação, para que Você Tenha Um Grau De Alucinação Menor Por Exemplo Então A Diferença Seria Essa.
Exatamente? Andrei.
Perfeito. ótimo, então, pessoal, deixa.
Eu abri aqui e a gente começa.
You mega Britt. Nesse projeto. Nesse processo é ótimo.
Fala aí, Eláide. Antes da gente começar. Deixa eu tirar um note aqui.
Wish, sir is one which.
Boa noite.
Eu, tenho uma pergunta aqui que eu estava vendo.
Design ali, design intensively.
Applications.
Eu esqueci agora qual, que é o livro. Eu até mandei hoje ali no.
I você já trabalharam em algum.
que levro.
Que a gente não vai ter tempo de descobrir todos os códigos e tudo mais vai ser bem difícil revisar fazer revisão. Por humanos então essas provas e lógicas matemáticas aí, ele sendo um cientista.
O Cleppmann.
Eu esqueci o nome dele também depois eu passo aqui para vocês se vocês quiserem então, é provas e lógicas matemáticas como é que está isso daí hoje em dia não sei se vocês já usaram.
é Assim Normalmente A Gente Vai Pra Td Day Quando Realmente Não Bate A Gente Vai Em Nível Matemático Uma das coisas que você pode fazer é criar chás ou criar hitmecs, ou algumas coisas de selo para verificar se aquela informação bate realmente, Mas Eu Nunca Entrei Nesse Nível De Detalhe Não.
Eu acho que no nível que ele explica ali, cara, é literalmente no nível de aplicações extremamente intensivas, principalmente. Ele é Muito Focado Em.
Sistemas de bordo em streaming. Coisa desse tipo que vai requerer algo mais nessa pegada.
Justamente pela quantidade de transações que está acontecendo.
Mas eu nunca especificamente tive que fazer algo desse jeito.
Ah não beleza então o td os testes ali vai cobrir maioria dos cases né.
Cara. Eu diria que assim.
Vai te cobrir noventa dos casos. E aí? Depois você vai ali.
Mas para a parte de resolver.
As arestas, eu diria, mas como priori sempre começar com o Tdd.
Beleza obrigado.
Isso depende muito, na verdade, se você está trabalhando com sistemas mais determinísticos, o Tbd, ele é ótimo.
Isso que você está falando? Para Cálculos, Matemática. Ele Funciona Muito Bem para Machine Learning Então Você Acaba Usando isso em modelos de borda, por exemplo, árvore de regressão ou alguns tipos de algoritmo de machine learning. Eu uso muito esse tipo de regra.
E a generativa, como ele é muito estocástico.
coaching, Excel coaching, realmente sabe questo me trabala ensima de.
workshop
um…
thing.
Teleforma saone ay tiena formacionus apartmas de specifico laado.
Legal, legal, regardless.
?
Uh-huh.
Belize.
Perfect.
Nod.
The shortbidity key.
The fate.
Come eso.
So I'm not sure key.
Tao.
I've been like on Machina.
Beleza. Bem, então deixa eu só ver se a gente já está gravando já. Então, pessoal, sejam bem vindos aí Ao nosso Segundo Dia da Semana da Engenharia Gêntica. E hoje, a Gente Vai Falar sobre Harness, né?
Eu diria que tá tudo que se relaciona em volta de Highness.
Uma das coisas que eu acho muito interessante é que.
O Hardness é um conceito relativamente novo. Obviamente, quando a gente olha esses anéis que a gente vai ver.
Muita coisa extremamente nova. Então eu já falar um pouquinho desse tempo.
Então quando. Eu olho para isso eu começo a entender, três coisas muito importantes aqui para vocês que. São? Nuggets aqui o primeiro nugget é eu preciso ter contexto do que eu vou fazer.
E o contexto está muito vinculado a.
Se a gente olhar uma camada acima qual a intenção o que eu quero fazer, qual o desejo é um feature request é uma nova implementação é um escopo maior ou assim por diante tá.
Então o que acontece nisso a gente quer literalmente aumentar a questão do contexto ou seja qual é o grounding que a gente vai fazer, em cima daquilo que a gente vai trabalhar segundo obviamente que eu quero buscar informações adicionais desse meu contexto né, e aí quanto mais.
Fontes de dados quanto mais uma forma fácil de eu recuperar essa informação melhor que é literalmente ter uma camada ontológica e terceiro se a gente, parar para pensar se eu tenho uma, intenção o prompt ali para começar a, destilar o que eu quero, eu tenho um contexto ontológico, ou uma base em que. Me traga essa informação.
Eu tenho que transformar, o quê em business requirement um requisito de negócio num technical requirement certo, nós de tecnologia, trabalhamos para isso e quando a gente, pensa nesse fluxo vocês concordam comigo que esse fluxo é canônico.
Eu acredito, muito que isso é um fluxo canônico e que, isso serve para qualquer caso, dentro da nossa área de tecnologia todas elas então cara começa com um request.
Que aqui a gente quer entender qual é a intenção depois dessa request eu tenho.
Eu tenho, um business requirement document então eu tenho, um business.
Document.
E aí. Depois desse business document eu tenho o, quê.
Eu tenho o prd ou, o técnico design então vou colocar technical document.
Vocês concordam que no final do, dia.
Isso aqui, se torna algo, comum para a gente.
Que vai compilar qualquer tipo, de coisa tanto, na área de requisito tanto, na área, de desenvolvimento de engenharia ai machine learning arquitetura qualquer coisa tem uma intenção eu compilo um documento com literalmente todas as informações de negócio mapeadas o máximo possível.
E depois eu, traduzo isso para um documento técnico porque esse documento técnico vai servir para a gente, para que a gente possa passar essas instruções para a gente bota no, chat aqui faz sentido para vocês sim ou não e se não faz por que não, faz vocês conseguem chegar isso como um processo canônico.
Então aqui a gente entende.
Aqui a gente tem literalmente a segunda parte disso que é o contexto né.
E, depois do contexto.
A gente tem a compilação dessa informação que é o documento.
Então quando a gente olha isso e deixa eu colocar aqui, para vocês no, chat.
Pause citar vários exemplos aqui por, exemplo eu tenho um frontind e eu quero fazer uma modificação quero assinar um novo botão beleza qual a intenção a intenção adicionar um novo botão no front end no sistema tal tal tal tal beleza essa é a intenção.
Essa intenção vai ser compilada num, documento explicativo como. Se fosse ali literalmente em um user story pensa no user story ali cara, o usuário quer fazer a modificação do sistema tal para adicionar, um botão para quintal usabilidade da ux e o x para poder fazer, isso tal tal tal tal então vai descrever, todo esse negócio e daí na hora que isso aqui sai ele vira o quê um documento técnico.
Então ele fala cara para poder fazer o que esse usuário fez no contexto que eu entendi nesse sistema o que a gente vai fazer pô a gente precisa ir, lá no, front end no? Css fazer essa modificação precisa criar essa nova classe e tal tal instanciar o botão para fazer. Isso isso e, isso, dessa forma, dessa forma.
Isso seria por, exemplo uma engenharia de software, um segundo por exemplo é poxa eu preciso fazer uma, otimização num job de spark qual é a requisição preciso fazer uma, otimização no job do, spark qual é o requisito qual é o user story.
O usuário tem, reclamado no, final porque o dashboard não está sendo, atualizado e foi identificado que isso tem a ver com o job despite que, antigamente executava em um minuto até executando em trinta e sete minutos causando lentidão no processo isso acontece no sistema.
Oregon que está causando isso isso assim assim assado beleza daí a gente tem o contexto alimentado e isso vira um documento técnico na instância tal no, job na degktal com o sistema tal que, gerou o plano de execução tal houve um problema tal tal tal tal é necessário fazer isso isso.
Reggae pô nosso reggae não está corrigindo não está, trazendo as informações é interessantes a gente está utilizando o bm, mas talvez, seja interessante utilizar o melhor tipo de pesquisa. Por causa que a gente está fazendo pesquisa semântica usuário.
O reggae hoje não retorna as, informações do, jeito que a gente, quer os usuários no bordo não tendo, as, informações, de confiabilidade está gerando uma má interpretação de texto que, está trazendo, mau resultado é necessário ser corrigido isso isso e aquilo.
Requisito técnico vector database que tem isso que hoje, faz chunks de quatrocentos e coloca vetoriza lá dentro tal tal não está utilizando hybrid search está utilizando somente o bm vinte e cinco é necessário fazer uma modificação no texto do retrieval na parte de retrieval para, poder fazer tal tal tal tal coisa.
Ficou. Agora claro qualquer coisa? Vira a intenção documento, de negócio e documento técnico.
Só, isso que eu estou falando para vocês aqui.
Já? É um, insight para vocês, entenderem, que tudo, que a gente, faz em tecnologia eventualmente usa o quê padrão framework.
Processo.
Porque é isso que faz a gente, ter velocidade e uma, fábrica de software uma, fábrica dark factory.
Entoin liter
Da intenção eu tenho o requisito de negócio tem um requisito de negócio eu tenho um requisito técnico.
Ficou, claro agora para todo mundo quero, que todo mundo esteja na mesma, página, aqui porque a gente. Vai começar a inteirar em cima disso aqui ficou claro claríssimo coloquem no, chat para mim.
Crystal crystal né beleza ótimo.
No isso não é engenharia de, contexto jorge não só engenharia de, contexto engenharia de, contexto é você preparar diante disso isso aqui, é um processo né esse aqui, é um processo.
Então o que é, engenharia de contexto a engenharia de contexto é você preparar.
Você preparar, a informação que um processo, um framework ou qualquer coisa, irá consumir, isso a engenharia de contexto são? Coisas, diferentes engenharia de contexto é você preparar o, contexto para que os agentes possam utilizar, então por exemplo.
Pô na hora em que o sistema genico o usuário vai pedir uma, requisição na hora que ele vai falar, pô eu preciso fazer uma, modificação no, front end tal tal, a engenharia de contexto eu entrei para falar cara, qual é o sistema aonde, eu pesquiso essa informação tem camada de ontologia não tem como que esse usuário se, conecta aqui.
Como que ele, busca dessa base isso é engenharia de contexto.
Belliz.
Ótimo então a gente, entendeu que o contexto é literalmente a parte crucial de qualquer projeto que a gente está pensando em implementar, porque é ela que vai ditar a regra do processo dito, isso a gente, vai olhar agora num, framing diferente e vai começar a entender as perspectivas do que, se conecta tudo isso.
A gente sai do prompt vai para o contexto e começa a falar literalmente do hardness e das unidades para que a gente possa transpilar isso então ontem a gente, entendeu teoricamente o problema, do cfo tem problema.
Basicamente de conseguir recuperar a, informação financeira até, porque isso pode significar várias coisas a gente viu ontem né a gente viu por exemplo que se ele perguntar quanto de, venda foi realizado isso pode ser um sql que executa ou a gente pode ter executado um sql.
Mas isso não quer dizer que queria, sequer está correto então, olha só que, importante a gente, entender aqui.
Primeira coisa é o modelo. Por si próprio ele não vai te entregar nada por quê porque o modelo no final, das contas é token, de entrada token de saída e é exatamente isso então por, isso que o harness é uma, característica muito, importante para o agente é o que torna ele um agente.
É o que. Sai de uma, interface de chat onde você está perguntando para o chat gpt ou, para o cloud lá desktop cara o que seria isso qual o melhor plano, para isso eu quero, criar uma, dieta assim assim assado pô a minha, filha tá fazendo, sete meses e ela vai viajar quais são, as coisas que eu tenho, que levar e assim por diante ela sai de uma, realidade onde ele vai, te responder.
E ele vai para uma, realidade muito maior de resposta e ação então o que é, o agents o que é um agente olha só que importante isso aqui vocês entenderem, é um modelo mais o hardness então a gente. Não é o modelo ou a gente também não é só o hardness.
O modelo é exatamente o modelo mais o harness e aí a gente começa a entender bem se o modelo se o agente é o modelo mais o harness.
O que significa hoje quando a gente começa a olhar todas as llns que nós temos ali hoje que são? Várias, tanto modelos open weight como modelos que são? Frontiers que são? Pagos e assim por diante quando a gente olha ali para o espectrum, hoje a gente tem muitas, coisas acontecendo nessa.
Corrida de llm que é uma, discussão bem legal de, falar que a gente vai falar na sexta feira.
Que é cara hoje a gente olha há seis meses, atrás a gente olhava o cláudio como literalmente dominante, no quesito de desenvolvimento seja basicamente o que, for.
Desenvolvimento sempre foi melhor do que todos os outros nos últimos, três quatro meses a gente teve o gpt cinco seis que literalmente foi um grande divisor de águas para o codex o codecs conseguiu literalmente fazer algo, que eu achava.
Muito difícil eles conseguiram fazer e daí logo depois deles começarem se equivaler teoricamente a gente começou a ver os modelos. Chineses realmente chegando muito perto.
Eh e não só muito perto eh como também em certas partes superior agora a questão é uma, coisa é o que eles falam que é o claiming o que eles dizem fazer, outra coisa é a vida real.
Por, exemplo eu não sei o quanto vocês usam diferentes modelos para trabalhar hoje mas hoje eu uso, várias coisas para trabalhar hoje o. Dia inteiro então eu trabalho muito, com kine trabalho muito com gpsy, que trabalho muito, com glm, trabalho muito com queen.
Que eu, acho que tem muita hype pelo menos, a qualidade do que eu faço deixou extremamente a desejar trabalho muito com o cláudio trabalho muito com codex trabalho muito com o grok, então assim na vida real você, olha os benchmarkings e você fala pô beleza.
Teoricamente o green tres dois é muito melhor ali superior do que o opus quatro oito cinco mas quando você vai fazer algo, específico.
Illusion. A realidade pelo menos a minha realidade é que ainda os modelos, frontiers. Batem muito nos modelos, chineses mas muito, e eu vou falar, duas características primeiro velocidade e segundo reasoning.
Essas são? As duas grandes características que eu reparei na minha experimentação no meu. Dia a dia isso é importante porque isso vai de, pessoa, para pessoa.
Isso vai para, vocês entenderem uma coisa que só a experiência vai te trazer por, isso que a gente, está aqui compartilhando porque essa informação que eu, vou falar para vocês agora não tem como você meter numa llm e ter um resultado.
Só, precisa de, você precisa viver. Por isso que eu acho que cada, vez mais treinamentos vão ser trocas de experiência e casos reais que a gente está vendo do que literalmente ficar ensinando conceitos o conceito tem que ver junto com o caso de uso, atrelado para você entender como aplicar tudo aquilo.
E aí o que, acontece na realidade mesmo na vida real na, minha vida real cloud e codec, dá banho em todos os axes primeiro velocidade a, velocidade dos, dois modelos são? Muito mais rápidos do que os modelos chineses e segundo reasoning é muito mais preciso.
Está, nas atividades, que eu desempenho então, assim e eu, desempenho vários tipos, de, utilidade, eu desempenho, desde atividades, de criação de html a criação de website a sincronização de bases reggae a tarefas atômicas, que a gente vai ver aqui então tem uma.
Cacetada de atividades que eu testo então pego às vezes vários modelos para fazer coisas iguais e. Literalmente eu expense então é uma coisa, que você deve fazer não ache que na hora que chegar um vídeo lindo ali falando gay em tres dois agora faz tal tal coisa enfim e você acredita que aquilo é melhor do que o cláudio enfim.
Claudio ultimamente anda muito ruim, quer dizer para ficar ruim. Ele, tem que melhorar muito existe um problema não sei se vocês sabem hoje mas quando, o opus v foi lançado.
Ele quebrou o formato de retrieval ele quebrou o formato de como ele retorna. A informação para você então muita gente aqui deve ter percebido, na hora de ter utilizado o cloud que ele começa a cuspir, umas paradas que é difícil de você entender de você ler e de você, realmente entender o que ele, está falando.
E, aí durante muito tempo eu me senti muito burro. Que eu falei cara, eu fiquei burro agora que eu não consigo entender o que ele fala velho é uma, linguagem muito complexa e aí literalmente isso foi achado literalmente no post training dele que existe uma, deficiência nisso, inclusive existem alguns fix.
Para que ele possa fazer isso então, esse tipo de coisa é péssimo para a gente que trabalha com isso todo, dia porque cara se você. Muda isso você traz, um tipo.
Muito mais complexo no final. Do, dia outra coisa que você tem problema quando você começa a trabalhar com multimodelos que para mim é o maior problema de todos não é nem em relação ao que ele vai executar e o que ele vai cuspir mas é como ele me retorna essa resposta.
Deixa eu perguntar uma coisa, quem aqui hoje utiliza mais de. Um.
Modelo.
Fala eu.
Mais de um e aí quando eu falo mais de um modelo eu estou falando de famílias diferentes ok eu estou falando de você utilizar, um openai um tropic não estou falando de você utilizar sonnet e opus não, tá.
Beleza se vocês utilizam mais de um então, acho que vocês, vão ter, esse mesmo problema que eu tenho vocês têm problema de alta.
Dificuldade de cognição ao longo do dia que é o seguinte.
Você lê o, output, do cloud é de uma forma você, lê o, output, do codec é de uma, outra forma você lê o output do kim é de uma outra forma então o seu gasto energético, ele, é muito grande porque não existe padronização de resposta de output.
Isso é muito nocivo então um dos problemas que vocês vão começar a ter quando, vocês começarem, a trabalhar aqui no trabalho como ultimodelo, é isso então existem modelos bons e modelos ruins, ali que possam fazer, isso para você, e te retornar.
Então outra coisa a gente está falando de tokenomics então o modelo é alugado o hardness, é construído então isso é uma coisa muito legal de entender então o modelo a gente pode imagina que você pode fazer o swapping trocar esse modelo todas as vezes mas o, hardness que você, constrói.
Ele literalmente se torna seu então. Por, isso que a gente começou a literalmente focar muito nesse conceito, de hardness ultimamente tá.
Each traz autoridade de você escrever o seu hardness do, jeito que é necessário para o seu problema e aí, que vai uma das coisas, da galera, que é agoniada de, plantão.
Vou falar de novo vou falar em todas as aulas você não aprender fundamento, você vai ser demitido.
Parece bem escroto o que eu estou falando mas é a verdade por quê por causa exatamente desse ponto aqui autoridade na escrita o que. Isso significa, cara.
Se você acha que você, vai pegar alguma coisa e você, vai utilizar, eu acho que você está redundamente enganado eu acredito muito que no, futuro ou, no que a gente está construindo cada pessoa se comunica e, ela trabalha de uma forma então existem, frameworks, meus existem, frameworks do rodrigo existem, frameworks do rafa existe.
Frameworks de, azul existe frameux do emerson e cada um gosta de trabalhar de uma, forma então com a llm ela te dá essa, capacidade de você, trabalhar da sua forma então qual é a parada legal disso é que você tem ali o seu two kit as coisas que você usa um usa bimed o outro usa spec kid o outro usa agent spec o outro usa dge o outro usa converge o outro usa vibe coding whatever.
No final. Do, dia você trabalha do jeito que você se sente melhor e você vai melhorando a sua stack só que tem um problema se você começa a ser um cara como, antigamente a gente, tinha a ideia dos, micrerosiros da galera que, ah vou usar isso vou usar aquilo vou usar aquilo e você, não entende o que está acontecendo. Por, debaixo sabe, o que, vai acontecer além, de você vai ter, um blowach emocional de.
Quantidade de coisas que, você tem que aprender você, não vai ter a base de você criar e adaptar aquilo que você, vai receber para algo que seja tailored que seja literalmente desenhado para a sua necessidade então harness não é uma coisa comprada.
É uma coisa escrita você precisa escrever o seu harness para endereçar um problema específico.
Não existe um hardness fits all né a gente tem esse conceito de meta hardness enfim e tal mas no final. Do, dia você precisa entender o que é para você, poder literalmente escrever então essa é a grande ideia do hardness e aí, onde a gente vai olhar quais. São, os anéis que a gente vai olhar hoje.
Então a gente vai olhar muito no anel do harness hoje em volta. Do harness em todos esses dias aqui a gente vai olhando aí, diferentes olha só que legal, então na segunda, feira ontem nós olhamos, a ideia do prompt.
Da criação dos specs do, contexto né hoje a gente vai olhar a questão do harness olha só como a gente está construindo o sistema como um todo.
Ah pô eu quero entender o que é graph, engineering tá beleza mas você, entende o que é spec driven você entende o, que é um contexto você entende realmente como harness e como criar um harness, não é só chegar para ele ali e falar cria um harness para, mim.
E aí, ele vai ter trezentos assumptions opa cara pediu um harness cara o que. Significa isso né.
Então você tem que entender cada camada dessa e por que ela existe tá e aí no dia quatro a gente vai explorar, o loop e os evolves que para mim hoje, é onde literalmente diferencia.
Um sistema e aí. Eu chamo, isso como, um sistema gêntico como um todo, para que você possa entregar qualidade, no final do dia e obviamente que a cada dia, que passa a gente, tem modelos sendo, lançados e melhorados e a gente vai começar nesse ciclo vicioso.
De ter eh atualizações constantes né então antigamente lembra que a atualização acontecia de seis, em seis, meses depois foi de quatro em quatro três em tres, dois agora um e cara às vezes você pega um mês que tem três quatro cinco lançamentos, diferentes então assim realmente é uma coisa de louco.
Hoje como a gente está lidando com todo, esse conceito então eu deixei uma imagem aqui muito clara do, que significa o agent como um todo né, que é o modelo mas o harness então se a gente olha para essa figura.
A gente está vendo, um zoom out a gente está ali olhando todos os, anéis da engenharia agêntica quando a gente, faz um clique ali dentro do harness do amarelo a gente entra dentro desse.
Esquema, aqui desse vesting aqui né do que, realmente é o harness no final. Do, dia né o que você tem que entender é que olha só que interessante eu inclusive deixei.
Esse cara aqui nesse círculo pra gente entender então quando a gente olha para um modelo veja que existe, um looping aqui então o modelo, por si próprio dentro de um harness qualquer então o loop alugado.
Os portões são construídos então quando você utiliza por exemplo um codex quando você utiliza um cloud code como você utiliza um kimicode quando você utiliza um groc code quando você utiliza qualquer ide ou qualquer ferramenta agêntica, um kiro e assim por diante você tem um harness.
Ele, é um harness o cloud ele, é um harness o cloud code é um harness então dentro desse harness, que é genérico você sempre tem o quê.
Pensar chamar observar e repetir. Então isso é literalmente canônico então todo looping porque aí muita gente, pergunta o seguinte. Cara e eu vou te falar uma confusão muito normal de saber que é o seguinte.
Aonde o lup se encaixa porque para muitas pessoas.
Muitas pessoas são? O seguinte não mas. Pô dentro do harness, eu tenho um loop.
Perfeito tem dentro do harness existe o loop existe o próprio loop do que o harness significa em cima dele que é exatamente o que eu falei aqui que é.
Pensar chamar observar e repetir, o harness. Faz isso.
Juanne já faz isso eu já tenho? Um loop aqui.
Então por que eu preciso desse, loop aqui de, cima por, que que essa engenharia de looping ela vai acima do harness.
Porque quando, a gente fala, de, engenharia de loop aqui de, loop engineering a gente está falando de algo um pouco mais complexo, e elevado que, junta algumas outras, características. Por, exemplo você quer dar um objetivo muito claro você quer injetar o contexto dos, outros anéis lá dentro você quer utilizar as características para embrulhar é o que a gente chama de bubble rapping a gente. Vai embrulhar.
O kulup de uma, forma em que eu falo olha para você, sair beleza você tem o seu loop normal que você vai executar vai fazer, o seu two. Do. List vai executar suas tarefas vai fazer tudo bonitinho tá.
Então flávio estou dando o caso de uso, agora então olha só imagina o seguinte eu chego para o cláudio e falo para ele o seguinte para vocês entenderem o que é um loop dentro do hardness e o que é um loop fora do harness eu digo isso porque ninguém vai te explicar, esse tipo de coisa.
Eu não conheço ninguém que te explica isso.
E aí, se você não entender isso você, vai patinar na hora que você, falar com alguém que conhece, então. Aprenda isso de uma vez o harness tem o loop tem muita gente, vai falar que. Não mas tem qual é o loop normal de um harness, de um agente.
É literalmente pensar.
Chamar observar e repetir está dentro do harness ok, agora o loop em cima ele controla de uma forma aonde pensa no seguinte eu chego para o cloud abro o chat e falo para ele, o seguinte cláudio.
Eu tenho esse pipeline de. Dados, eu estou com um problema no, dbt, eu preciso criar, por exemplo uma nova.
Uma nova tabela, silver com a lógica das tabelas. Bronzes de projeto de, sei lá.
De finanças, e de pedidos e de order details.
Beleza o que o harness, vai fazer receber, o contexto foi lá ler o seu code base ler os repositórios e falou opa entendi aqui que você quer que eu crie uma nova camada silver olhando a tabela de orders e orders details que está na bronze.
E agora eu vou começar a pensar nisso aí ele, vai fazer várias, validações, lá pô isso existe não enfim tal tal ele tá dentro do harness prestem atenção isso é importante ele está dentro do harness beleza tá lá dentro aí ele vai falar o seguinte. Ele vai criar o, codec.
Ou, clouds e você vê isso ele, vai criar o próprio título list dele vai falar, pô beleza eu tenho que verificar bronze eu tenho que verificar as colunas eu tenho que materializar o silvio eu tenho que verificar quais são, as lógicas e aí, ele vai trabalhar no próprio loop dele.
De literalmente pensar chamar observar e repetir ele. Vai ficar. Fazendo. Isso.
Que é literalmente react.
Reason plus act isso você aprende lá na, formação que a gente, tem inclusive aí o rafa a gente, fala muito sobre isso tem um módulo só de fundamentos para explicar cada um deles em várias horas aí então beleza então ele, vai lá fazendo, isso.
E daí, ele fala quando ele saiu do loop, ele fala, pô beleza criei a bronze quer dizer verifiquei a bronze criei a silver.
Aí depois da silver eu literalmente criei o código e beleza está pronto.
Beleza.
Qual critério de aprovação disso.
Saco.
Quais são as características que dizem, que aquilo que você escreveu ou, que aquilo que você fez literalmente foi aprovado testado e validado.
Nenhuma é daí que o loop mais o ival entra então você, faz um bubble rapping você embrulha o seu hardness e fala o seguinte. Olha o objetivo por, isso que você, vai ver no codec você vai ver no kim ring gol.
É literalmente um loop em, cima do harness ele vai, falar o seguinte olha.
Para que você possa literalmente considerar isso eu preciso que você, faça uma verificação se aquele código escreveu se o linking funcionou do código se você consegue, acessar tal coisa você dá um objetivo para ele perseguir e daí. Ele vai criar.
Uma, série de sucessos de critério, para poder te ajudar nisso, só que ainda tem um problema.
Que é o que o rafa vai explicar no dia, quatro ele, está falando quais são, os critérios de sucesso dele.
E daí que você traz, o evol engineering que é opa amigão calma aí, eu vou te falar quais são? Os critérios que eu quero para você falar pra mim. Então os meus critérios os meus e vols, são, o seguinte, faz um dbt, model chama clá e faz isso verifica que aquele dado tá.
Persiste isso me, traz o retrieval me faz um select na tabela materializada do big square me traz, o retorno, e só após isso você sai do, loop então ele tem o loop do harness e ele tem, um loop do loop.
Sacou foda ficou claro para vocês agora.
Bom deu para entender, agora a diferença de loop, loop, loop, porque o harness tem loop o loop, tem loop, o e volta em loop então só para vocês entenderem as características, de cada um desses anéis.
Isso te torna, um engenheiro fora, da curva quem quanto mais. Fundamento, quanto mais eu entendo, mais eu guio a ia melhor.
Ponto indiscutível o luan fala de fundamentos que é importante quem me acompanha aí há mais de sei lá deve ter gente que me acompanha aqui há mais de dez anos eu sempre falo sobre isso.
Eu já paro para tirar algumas perguntas sempre falo cara fundamentos a galera ah não quero ver a demo cara fundamentos não vocês demoram demais falando de fundamentos é mas aí, você reprova porque você. Não tem um fundamento, quando o cara te coloca um caso de, uso, eu te falo. Mas por, que você.
Mas como que eu uso, um looping engineer aqui no, meu caso.
Você, vai falar, você, não sabe você não sabe. Por, quê você é o cara que, pega, um bocado de, framework utiliza e não entende porquê por quê porque você, não começa, de cima para baixo, de basta, então, você constrói a fundação para ser extremamente fácil então.
Coloquem isso tá.
Na cabeça de vocês, tá.
Agora o vinícius falou o seguinte luan você não acha que em algum momento lupe volxtão integrados no harness eu não acho que no harness, eu acho que no processo como um todo, acho que cada, vez mais, a tendência é, simplificação e aí uma das coisas que eu gosto.
De pensar nisso, é que a simplificação gera.
Pedaços e loucunas abertas então por exemplo antigamente não existia gol.
Hoje você dá um codecs lá e, você dá um barra, gol ou, seja você está literalmente abstraindo toda essa, complexidade, que se, fala, de looping enfim para as, ideias lembra, que você tem, os sistemas de vocês, que vão, atender os clientes, ou que, vai fazer, whatever que vocês querem.
Então eventualmente ele vai gerar o evol para você eventualmente ele já vai ordenar o gráfico para você mas sabe uma coisa que nunca vai mudar na minha humilde opinião.
O, framework, a intenção, para, mim hoje e para os próximos. Anos e eu me cubro com muita pesquisa para falar isso, para vocês, porque eu estou, no blaring edge, justamente para poder falar cara, essa é a direção aqui, isso aqui, não vai dar certo isso aqui, dá certo.
A intenção vai continuar sempre, rafa o que você acredita se você puder falar desculpa eu ficar te chamando aí. Mas, é porque é um tipo de conversa que geralmente não tem com tantas pessoas mas o que você acredita eu acredito que cara muita coisa vai ser teoricamente padronizada. Mas o que você acredita que vai ser ainda algo que nós como engenheiros.
Queremos constantemente trabalhar.
Eu Acho Que A Gente, Vai Trabalhar Muito Eu Acho Que à Medida Que As Coisas Vão Desenvolvendo A Gente vai ter agentes tratando com agentes. Então a autonomia de agentes vai aumentar cada vez mais. Isso é o que a gente ouve muito. O Boris Charlie Falando.
Vamos chegar nesse ponto.
O que eu acho que a gente vai ter que chegar como engenheiros é ter confiabilidade no que a gente Está Fazendo Então O Processo De Entrega.
Como a gente faz a entrega e como a gente valida. Isso é onde a gente vai ter que realmente Focar Especificamente O Nosso Trabalho.
Então eu acho que igual eu falei ontem. Eu acho que a análise de dados vai vir muito forte. Eu Acho Que A Parte De Validação Vai Vir Muito Forte A Parte De.
Que vai mudar um pouco para o Forest Delivery Engineer, que é o cara que vai estar ali junto com o cliente. Então.
Cliente vai passar alguma definição. Esse cara vai criar uma Pock rápida e vai passar isso para um time de Estabilidade Então Acho Que A Gente Vai Ir Para Um Processo Mais Rápido De Entrega.
E sente assim confiabilidade, porque isso é uma coisa que a gente não consegue definir dentro da engenharia agêntica, né?
E você.
Bom. Pode falar.
Você acredita que a gente consegue automatizar a intenção e, contexto.
O contexto. Eu acho que ele vai melhorar muito. Eu acho que a gente ainda tem muita coisa no mercado Acontecendo Então O Pessoal Fala Muito De Colocar Grafo Dentro Do Contexto Então Eu Acho Que Tem Muita Coisa Tem Muita.
Muita teoria, ainda em cima. Intenção, não intenção. Eu acho que realmente isso aí vai ser o ponto. Então, o Que A Gente, Vai Ter Vai Ser A Entrada E Como A Gente Valida A Saída.
I see the, mesh.
O meio do caminho. Eu acho que ele vai ser uma caixa preta.
Exatamente.
Cadach factory é literalmente um dark factory exatamente ou seja o luan doido está falando um bocado de coisa doida por causa disso porque é o que o rafa falou a intenção na minha humilde opinião ela nunca vai ser tirada do engenheiro porque a intenção é literalmente o que você, quer e o que, você precisa do sistema.
Muita gente vai te falar o seguinte. Alô mas a gente, vai chegar num nível em que um presidente vai compilar a intenção errado não vai.
Por que ele, não vai, porque para você, compilar, a intenção, você precisa entender você precisa entrar em, acordo com a máquina você, precisa ter especificidade naquilo entendeu então pô o presidente pode construir, um front end pode claro que ele pode mas você acha que vai ser, na mesma qualidade para quando, você precisa literalmente elevar esses sistemas.
E isso vai muito de, acordo com o que, às vezes eu e o rafa estamos falando coisas diferentes mas é a mesma coisa que é por exemplo o negócio dos, arquétipos então por exemplo o boris churn? Que ele falou ali não acredita muito mais, em engenheiro de software, pm enfim.
Ele acredita muito nessa ideia de arquétipos que eu vou falar para vocês na sexta feira sobre as profissões do futuro então cara você tem um cara que vai prototipar você tem um cara, que vai literalmente trazer para. A produção vai ter um cara que vai escalar então você vai ter todo. Esse processo.
Você quer falar, rafa fala aí.
Não Eu Acho Que é Exatamente Isso né? Assim Eu Acho Que Qualquer Pessoa Mais Para O Futuro Vai Conseguir mandar a intenção. Então a pessoa vai conseguir falar. Mas tem um meme que eu acho muito engraçado que o cara fala assim aparece Muito No Linkedin O Cara Fala Agora Eu Não Preciso Mais De Engenheiro De Software Eu Construí Meu Sistema Rp Aqui.
Em três horas. Aí o outro responde embaixo. E eu demorei cinco minutos para hackear ele. Então eu acho que é Exatamente Essa Ideia.
Exatamente perfeito.
Então se vocês entenderem tudo isso que eu, estou passando, para vocês extrapolarem um pouco a curva, a ideia para vocês continuarem dominantes ganharem muito dinheiro porque existe muita abertura, para ganhar dinheiro porque a gente vai ganhar mais dinheiro do que antes.
Porque o que vai acontecer, o que é início e meio vai ser cortado e literalmente quem sabe, o que está compilando intenção entende, de engenharia de software de dados, de a consegue ser um forno depois de, dinheiro para entender o problema deixa lá isso não é, intenção acompanhar a fábrica.
Criar, os involves validar, o retorno, criar as, automações em cima. Disso e tudo isso essa pessoa vai ganhar, muito dinheiro.
Para os próximos. Anos então entra no meu sas, localúcho oitenta oitenta boa.
Curtir deixa eu tentar aqui, tá então eu já abro? Para perguntas então ficou claro que agora o agente é o modelo mais, o harness né então a gente tem um inside out agora em que o que a gente começa a ter dentro do hardness primeira coisa, contexto.
Que vai ser herdado de, algum local e para mim na, minha opinião.
Nível enterprise contexto.
É contexto contexto e redução de alucinação em grande escala.
Até porque quando a gente começa a pensar em dado estruturado é mais fácil agora pensa numa empresa que tem teras e teras e terabytes de, dados documentos com versão um para versão duzentos várias, coisas como você, controla isso e acha, qual, é a verdade e não somente isso cria uma camada de, acesso em que você possa fazer literalmente o retrieval a recuperação dessa informação na hora correta da forma, correta.
Então eu acho muito que toda parte que está, envolta, ao contexto é uma parte muito válida para a enterprise muito válida que vai crescer muito tem muita coisa para melhorar. Mas eu ainda acredito fielmente que.
Se o dado é ruim.
Você vai tendenciosamente cuspir, coisas ruins e obviamente, que a gente, vai tentar acionar isso utilizando ontologia, o que vai melhorar muito principalmente para descobrir, os erros e corrigir esses erros mas.
É um jogo, da cauda, longa, não o jogo, da cauda curta tá então o contexto é algo, que eu falo para vocês, pode passar bastante tempo em contexto que é algo. Frutífero pode passar muito tempo em harvard porque é uma, coisa de, novo é uma coisa em que você cria então ela é customizada para a sua necessidade.
E o rafa, vai falar na quinta feira sobre a importância dos vai trazer umas coisinhas aqui e aí, vocês vão entender por que o ival na verdade ele é muito mais, importante do que todas essas outras camadas o que você quer fazer, é compilar a intenção.
E vai lhe dar o resultado.
Se, os dois estão validados se você consegue fazer, isso o meio tanto importa no final. Do, dia.
Então a primeira coisa é o contexto em que ele reside depois são? As ferramentas que ele tem.
Depois quais são as políticas que ele pode quais são as regras quais são? As específicas permissões que ele tem quais. São? As condições para ele parar.
Pô cara se você ficar, mais de trinta minutos rodando aqui para pô se você gastar um milhão de tokens para pô se em algum momento você bater uma lógica em que você tentou ela duas três vezes para então você tem, esse top conditions que. São? As políticas tá e você tem as verificações.
O que significa completo no seu harness o que significa isso para você então esses quatro pontos mostram exatamente qual é a capacidade, de um sistema em que, constrói e, faz harness.
E olha só. Que interessante o loop, é genérico o hardness é seu então o que seria um loop.
Um loop nada mais é do que um aisle.
Então se você olhar ali o cloud code ele é um while no final do, dia.
Então ele tem ali o chamo modelo reasoning passa o contexto depois a ação pega qual a ferramenta o resultado ele executa uma, ação e o contexto recebe ele mais o resultado.
Ele observa, que continua nesse looping.
Isso é um looping dentro do harness.
Agora o harness, em si olha só. Que interessante opa eu vou construir um harness em que a gente, vai construir isso hoje tá eu vou construir, um harness onde o meu, contexto vai olhar para, o agents mid, vai olhar para, o stories, de specs, que é onde estão as minhas evidências.
Eu vou chamar uma ferramenta, que é a, permissionamento, dentro do postgress eu vou chamar, o dbt que é, a cli do, dbt e eu vou chamar o make para que, me dá as características, de acessar as ferramentas a minha política é de writeable paths, eu tenho permissão, de escrever.
E eu tenho regras de permissionamentos de parada e eu vou delegar isso para uma, agente olha só de julgamento então pô para ele validar a minha arquitetura depois eu vou chamar um agente de desenvolvimento.
Yeah eu vou verificar.
Fazendo, o quê um make dbt cheque está vendo, isso aqui é basicamente eu não vou chamar isso de vol mas. Isso é uma validação então aqui você tem, um make dbt check para, verificar, realmente se aquilo foi feito, você, tem, um validator que pode ser uma cli que você constrói olha só que loucura então por mais que os sistemas não, sejam determinísticos o llm, não é determinístico.
Mas, a chamada dentro de um harness pode ser no, final ele, vai te retornar zero um porque você pode pedir para o seu hardness chamar uma cli.
The scla é determinística tá e por fim você tem um humano.
No gate.
E daí você consegue, literalmente fazer o quê.
Amarrar e embrulhar o modelo dentro do harness.
Bem.
Antes de prosseguir vamos pegar algumas, perguntas aqui, ayrton.
É luan eu tenho reparado que.
Os modelos frontiers gpt.
Cloud enfim parece que cada, vez mais eles pegam as necessidades que a gente tem de hardness e coloca para dentro.
Então.
Eu, por exemplo hoje uso, opus eu já desinstalei várias skills, plugins.
Porque meio que parece que foi, pior e quando eu tirei ficou melhor.
Vocês, percebem a mesma, coisa é isso mesmo, que está rolando.
É é isso mesmo, é exatamente isso na verdade se você, olhar pelo i combinator.
Eu recomendo eu vou deixar aqui o link para vocês, porque é uma parada que vale a, pena vocês verem.
Veja.
Ia entrevista porque ela é muito recente então assim.
Vale a, pena vocês assistirem ela como um todo. São, trinta e cinco minutos tá.
Mas assim essa é uma, parada que vale muito a pena vocês verem basicamente o que ele a recomendação do boris agora.
Quem não sabe esse cara que é, o criador, do cloud code.
Ele quer ele ele recomenda fortemente.
Que você tire skill que você, tire contexto que você tire tudo que dá para tirar o máximo possível por quê porque o opus hoje está tão inteligente que a ideia é só você literalmente criar esse.
Finn hardness, que na verdade não é mais conhecido como harness é conhecido como uma coisa que eu, acho que ninguém conhece aqui alguém, sabe qual é o nome, disso.
Uma camada thin layer que não está mais no harness.
Alguém chuta qual seria o nome, não não aflite.
Que a gente usa bastante que eles usam bastante hoje para não chamar de harness.
Então vocês vão aprender num treinamento, de noventa e sete olha só que coisa louca né é muito caro.
Mega brain acertou não é looping então o que acontece assista o que o boris fala mas a ideia é exatamente tirar tirar o máximo possível deixar o mínimo possível e aí o que, ele fala beleza para você fazer, isso você tem que, ter o.
Objetivos claros.
Objetivos muito claros uma, boa documentação no. Seu repositório e isso vai te ajudar extremamente então essa é uma coisa que você pode fazer com opus na verdade o opus fica muito mais burro.
Quando você passa muita informação para ele inclusive. Eu estou com esse problema, num projeto de, tres dois milhões de linhas hoje porque eu tinha muita coisa que funcionava muito bem para o k tres que funcionava para o opus quatro oito até para o fable mas no opus v.
Como o reasoning dele é diferente dos outros tá é diferente do quatro oito e do fable ele tende a literalmente não necessitar mais de, coisas mais explícitas então ele, é muito bom em descobrir certas coisas.
Você está no caminho certo tá retire. Mas, mantenha tem muita coisa que funciona muito bem ainda a ideia é não tenta, poluir demais deixa mais limpo, tá.
Carol.
Boa, noite.
Open boa noite, só para conseguir aqui fixar, o entendimento do hardness aqui né se. Eu der o exemplo de um etl, que utiliza, duas, degs e um backend, em python e aí tem uma, deg que, censora um arquivo no pentágono, envia para a segunda deg e, a segunda deg junto com o backend em python.
Faz as execuções ali, faz o enriquecimento desse arquivo obviamente consultando algumas bases, de dados, depois devolve esse, arquivo enriquecido, no, pentágro, para o cliente.
Aí digamos que a gente está com esse back end em python é macarrônico né muita gambiarra muito tem até três men, lá dentro pra você ter uma ideia e aí, eu peguei o desafio de fazer a refotoração disso de uma coisa muito mais simples e mais.
Melhora culturalmente como é que seria o harness dentro desse projeto de reestruturação desse etr por, exemplo.
Primeira coisa é começar pequeno e não pensar no, hardness porque a primeira coisa que você tem que entender é qual a, intenção que você quer eu quero refracturar tá mas.
O que significa, refaturação para você você, quer reduzir quantidade de ideia você quer melhorar a performance você quer utilizar um novo modelo no eflow o que você quer fazer então primeiro entender a intenção.
Segundo criar. Um bom contexto.
Depois gerar uma, especificação. Do, que você quer e aí, sim você vai pensar em criar um hardness. Por exemplo o que eu faria na verdade é exatamente esse processo entender muito bem a intenção gerar um requisito que é o que eu falei ali gerar, o requisito de negócio do requisito, de negócio gerar, o requisito técnico em todas as coisas que você, tem, que fazer, então pedir, para o agente, extensionar o. Código.
Verifying tal daí, fazer uma pesquisa profunda dentro dessa especificação para falar cara qual, o design pattern que eu vou utilizar quais são? As melhores práticas, qual redução de, corte que eu, vou fazer quais são? Os testes onde vai ser o deployment enfim uma vez que eu tenho essa ideia, muito bem, colocada na, minha cabeça daí, eu vou pensar em construir o hard.
Que vai ser. Por exemplo vou pegar aqui numa coisa bem simples pô eu vou construir. Por exemplo um harness onde ele, olha. O contexto da deg ele, refatora, num outro ambiente num docker e ele, testa isso fim a fim eu faço uma geração de dados para garantir que esse dado está, fim a fim e aí eu construo por exemplo três níveis ali de agentes eu crio um arquiteto para revisar eu crio um desenvolvedor.
Para poder escrever eu crio um desenvolvedor para desenvolver um revisor para revisar o código eu crio um observador para validar de uma outra família de llm para verificar se aquele, código, que eu escrevi realmente foi feito ou não e daí, você vai aprendendo, a fazer, isso, a, melhor, forma, que você tem, que fazer, é small bite chunks é pegar esse, problema grande.
Okay braile micro pedaços e passar do início até o fim qual é o início até o fim se, você seguir.
I see george, isto eu coloquei aqui.
Você consegue fazer o seu, problema você vai para o optar, o que você, quer vai gravar um contexto dessa informação vai criar uma, especificação nisso, vai gerar, um hardness para fazer. Toda essa validação depois vai adicionar um objetivo.
Consequentemente vai adicionar, um critério de validação e depois você, vai automatizar, isso via grafo falar, pô beleza agora toda a requisição que eu receber de uma nova, deg eu vou passar. Por, esse design pattern vai fazer, isso vai fazer, isso isso no final, dessa construção aqui você vai, ter basicamente uma dark factory.
Basicamente isso.
Última pergunta vai lá.
Opa é seguinte eu faço bastante postagem no linkedin daí, eu vejo sempre o pessoal rodando modelos vocais e cada vez mais esses modelos locais estão ficando porretão assim e aí não seria o caso de já começar a testar esses modelos locais para não ficar refém.
Tem tanto de rede quanto cai porque se cair um ali você já? Fica com o teu hardness alguém está testando vocês estão fazendo. Isso.
Tem alguma sei lá.
Uma ideia de.
Eu ainda não tenho, máquina, para, poder fazer isso mas eu, acho que eventualmente a gente vai conseguir fazer, muita coisa nesse espectro e eu acredito que isso é uma emoção muito grande do mercado como um todo, tem esse site aqui que, eu não sei se, todo mundo, conhece chamado, ansl.
Que ele é um cara bem legal porque na verdade ele é um ambiente basicamente ali onde você, pode puxar os seus modelos e você tem toda essa. Interface local então você pode construir a integração do seu agente viola aqui ou qualquer coisa e ele baixa essa informação local para você e você consegue utilizar cara é muito legal.
Só, que você precisa ter máquina então aqui a ideia é você literalmente compilar esse cara cem local e você tem vários modelos que você pode simplesmente trabalhar nele, ele te diz quais. São, os softwares quais são? As informações quais são? Os rádios que você tem então por exemplo aqui.
Para você rodar o deep psique v, quatro local.
O que você, precisa então teoricamente você, precisa de.
Sete gigas que quatro cem e tal ele basicamente te explica o que, você precisa e aí, você tem as configurações que você, pode endereçar aqui mas ó tabela, de inferência então se você, perguntar lá na ln m cara eu tenho uma, máquina. Tal tal eu quero fazer basicamente.
Esse modelo como que, eu faço. Isso então basicamente ele te mostra aqui, como rodar o modelo e o legal é que ele te entrega aquela interface ali bonitinha para você utilizar.
Então é um cara legal de usar, deixa eu deixar aqui, um sloth.
Very fair, huh.
Beleza deixa eu seguir. Depois andré, eu pego a, sua pergunta, tá.
Beleza então vamos lá.
O que a gente vai pensar naquilo que a gente falou.
O igor tinha falado ali sobre os harness enfim inclusive, eu quis trazer. Isso aqui porque é uma, coisa importante.
Todos os hamins produzem o mesmo resultado então a gente viu na verdade que não por quê quando a gente rodou o cloud ele recordou lá que oitenta e seis mil foram capturados e a margem foi de noventa e dois milhões o gpt cinco seis.
Basicamente deu uma informação toda estruturada. Mas. Não deu as informações o deep psic já falou que era noventa e cinco milhões, de grows em vez de noventa e dois do opus o grok já respondeu muito bem não tem revenue no esquema ele foi inteligente pra caramba aqui parabéns para ele.
Então o que a gente fez aqui aqui está uma questão muito mais, de percepção, muito vinculada, ao prompt, ao contexto do que literalmente ao harness então quando a gente olha para o prompt a gente tem esses desvios mas o que a gente vai fazer, é garantir que o hardness consiga mover de acordo com o que a gente, quer como a gente, quer.
Então a gente vê isso acontecer e a gente, vai começar a olhar como a gente vai corrigir esse cara aqui então primeiro ponto.
O mesmo modelo harness. Diferentes existe realmente algo que suporte isso que a gente está falando sim então por exemplo o time da openai que inclusive foi, um dos primeiros, times inclusive deixa eu mostrar aqui.
Sobre o.
Is engineering esse é um artigo muito bom de ler openai, acho que vai ser o primeiro artigo, que vai aparecer.
Feito pelo ryan lopopolo é um cara legal também de vocês pesquisar esse cara sabe muito sobre hardness ele na verdade, é um dos, percursores de harness, dentro da openai então é um cara bem legal de vocês é um artigo, que eu, li realmente ali não, pedi para a ia fazer, eu realmente.
Ali, porque é um artigo, muito rico que, mostra como, eles pensam em harness como que, eles fazem hardness. E como existe tudo isso é, um artigo muito rico um artigo que eu recomendo vocês lerem então literalmente o que, eles fizeram é linhas chipadas nos últimos cinco meses com linhas escritas por, mão de três engenheiros fizeram mais de um quinhentos merges de pr utilizando, o codec cem em um harness.
Em modelos diferentes tá um outro ponto é existem alguns indicadores por exemplo que te trazem treze sete, pontos em cima da troca de modelo onde você literalmente tem melhoria, justamente pela utilização do hardness.
E também tem um cara chamado harness bent que foi, criado que te traz alguns, pontos quando você. Faz o que com tarefas idênticas, similares quando você muda o modelo e você, deixa o mesmo hardness, você tem vinte e três pontos a mais de que você consiga executar aquela tarefa.
Com exatidão então literalmente o hardness faz total diferença em como você encapsula o modelo, e é uma, das coisas que a gente já vê para o futuro com certeza quanto mais a gente vê modelos, locais modelos chineses modelos japoneses modelos, americanos, e daqui a pouco a gente vai ter uma, outra categoria de modelos chegando aí no mercado também então a gente vai começar a ver um pouquinho dessa, destilação acontecendo.
Agora.
O que a gente tem até o momento então a gente tem aqui as informações.
Do artigo. Do documento técnico da ontologia e literalmente só, um empty shell do dbt então a gente viu somente essa informação básica aqui então vamos ver. Se realmente a gente tem, essas informações.
Lá dentro então se a gente, for olhar literalmente o que a gente viu.
Está faltando modelo tupiniquim verdade tá.
O que a gente consegue ver né se a gente, for em histórias, de specs nós temos, três specs aqui para, a gente lembrar da aula de ontem primeiro spec é o contexto né então a questão literalmente é quanto de vendas, a transactico, fez.
Ontem né e por que a gente deve confiar nesse número primeira coisa é que ontem já mudou na perspectiva do que foi feito então esse é o primeiro, ponto que é, extremamente importante segundo.
As for de Kifa capurad
como.
trabala mais escreve, porque voce via brico un contestos limpos, entomo que mais interracentista, entao sebuo le que gente pego, gravo contesto.
A que le tem uma evidencia de leger, neo do que fui verificado, co esamos fatos importantes, na toa. Re aumente
Entao.
I.e. Us pagamitos e podem traseru page at condo cuando Fido. Tao entao que se tem lejera as evidences cojetas. Deposiento de reconciliaccao.
Est
Agente da injera de Academy.
Mas.
Infra so tore dia, o outo grande mundo, dac factory o se de toda parte agentica. E eu que voce decada
É o conceito de engenharia, agêntica, que é, exatamente tudo isso que a gente, está conversando aqui então aqui, a gente tem camada de ontologia.
A gente tem as informações físicas né do que significa então olha só as pessoas perguntam o que é uma ontologia olha aqui na sua, cara o que é ontologia o fato físico.
Orders, ponto total.
Amount.
É, a soma do, número a soma para um número preciso essa, mesma pergunta olha só, que legal.
Yes realmente esse pedido acontece alguma coisa antes, disso acontecer então olha o significado do negócio isso aqui realmente essa informação realmente significa, que essa informação foi capturada e reconhecida como um evento orders estaras que têm.
Diferentes valores quais. São, os status que contribuem e quais. São os subtros do que é retornado o que é válido o que, não é eu tenho três relógios ali qual relógio define ontem em qual time zone.
Isso ontologia.
Alright estou respondendo literalmente o que significa ter tres relógios ali.
E qual, contexto dessa, ontologia.
Então totalmente diferente da, ideia da gente ter um, reggae por exemplo, tá então só para vocês entenderem, a diferença entre, eles.
Beleza aí a gente tem aqui, também as informações do que não foi resolvido porque o significado da venda pode ter várias informações para a gente.
Né quais são, as decisões que estão abertas então primeira coisa, o engenheiro agente como uma engenheira agêntica.
Precisa ler precisa ter interpretação de texto e precisa ter paciência, e aí você olha para mim e fala paciência, é porque hoje o nosso cérebro. É, frito já né? Então por exemplo quem consegue ler um documento desse poucas, pessoas.
E ainda tem a segunda característica ler interpretar.
Entender né então assim adiciona, um grau muito grande de, complexidade, pode parecer besta, que eu estou falando mas na verdade. Não é então o que eu quero, dizer com isso.
Tenta voltar a ideia de tentar ler um livro, isso é uma coisa muito importante muita gente aqui não consegue eu sou uma dessas pessoas que tento a questão é tentar um dia você vai conseguir tenta ler livro literalmente ler o livro.
Páginas porque a gente está num mundo hoje de ficar rouletando scrolling toda hora quando você pega um livro ali para ler você não consegue ler então você, precisa tentar se retreinar ter paciência, em ler em ter boas técnicas, de poder ter interpretar texto.
Ter técnicas de absorver de compactar esse é o futuro.
Quem, souber fazer, isso muito bem, vai ter uma vantagem significativa tá do que as outras. Pessoas.
Com, certeza tá.
E daí dez informações, a gente compilou o quê um documento técnico então olha só, que importante isso aqui, documento técnico.
Tá ok.
Pending, pré review beleza então a gente, precisa responder as informações que foram colocadas lá na ontologia.
A questão quanto que foi vendido ontem que por que a gente deve confiar nessa informação o que a evidência suporta a gente, tem algumas informações aqui que podem ajudar a gente, beleza o que o ledger, faz o claiming.
O cefo pode confiar nessas informações.
Qual literalmente são, as informações importantes para a gente ter então a gente tem os substratos aqui, a gente, tem algumas informações muito importantes que a gente construiu ontem nesse processo de investigação então a gente entendeu esses documentos.
E agora eh o que a gente vai conseguir com isso é literalmente respirar ler e tentar entender.
Tudo isso o que, faz sentido o que. Não faz sentido em uma dica muito importante para vocês aqui.
Tente fazer essas atividades que necessitam de uma carga cognitiva muito grande no começo do seu dia ao invés do final. Do seu dia independentemente do seu ciclo circadiano do que você acha que é melhor porque eu sou uma, pessoa noturna e assim por diante.
Independente se você seja uma pessoa noturna diurna tanto, faz quando você acorda a sua área, cognitiva muito maior do que. Depois de doze horas trabalhando que oito horas trabalhando então sempre tente colocar técnicas na sua cabeça de conseguir destilar, coisas que são? Importantes.
No nas primeiras horas do seu dia isso que é muito importante você ler entender e digerir e é só isso que vai fazer, você, se tornar, um engenheiro de dados, ou um engenheiro agente com um engenheiro de, software muito, bom nos dias de, hoje lê entender.
Questionar ser curioso interar verificar é esse processo hoje não é inscrever código está vendo, que a gente está falando basicamente seis horas já perto de seis horas e a gente, não falou de escrever uma linha de código porque não faz sentido mais fazer isso nenhum.
Não, faz sentido nenhum, faz sentido você entender o que está sendo escrito em vários níveis ali então realmente prestem atenção nisso.
E aí quando a gente olha para esses três arquivos.
A gente começa a entender que existe uma coisa interessante aqui.
Que é se a gente, falou de compilar intenção e, de entender literalmente o que é um requisito técnico um requisito de negócio vira um requisito, técnico.
Como que a gente consegue dividir esses slices como que a gente consegue literalmente trabalhar essa segregação e daí o que eu, identifiquei ao longo, dessa minha jornada como.
For deploy engineer ou como ai engineer.
Fale do jeito que quiser.
Foi como que a gente consegue dividir trabalhos.
De uma forma inteligente.
E daí eu comecei a, ficar muito inquieto com isso porque olha, esse insight que, eu vou dar aqui, para vocês, vocês, podem, né, seria muito legal se vocês tiverem, os insights, do foda então vou tentar explicar qual, é, a grande, ideia aqui, então uma das coisas que eu, tentei fazer, me apoiar aos ombros, de gigantes e começar a pesquisar.
Como que a gente consegue dividir trabalhos.
O que é dividir trabalhos cara, você tem um escopo muito grande, né então só para vocês entenderem porque isso aqui, é muito importante vocês entenderem talvez mais, importante do que vocês entendam o que é importante.
O que acontece quando você tem uma intenção essa, intenção é compilada num documento técnico que a gente, vai criar sempre cara, dentro desse documento, técnico.
Dentro desse documento de negócio que vira um documento técnico esse, documento técnico pode ter várias divisões você. Concorda, comigo então pode ser somente uma feature como dentro desse documento técnico você, descobre que você tem, que fazer coisa, de front end.
Você tem que fazer coisa de back end.
Você tem, que fazer coisa de reggae você tem que fazer coisa de pipeline.
Então como que você. Decompõe, isso.
Esse é um dos maiores problemas que eu tive durante muito tempo.
Oh diria ali tranquilamente três quatro cinco meses por quê porque quando alguém chega.
Para, te pedir alguma coisa, ele, não pede em bullet point ele, não pede de forma simples ele vai cuspir no texto ó, eu quero, fazer, tal coisa, que eu estou pensando em fazer, assim assado cor, assim aí, eu quero. Agora uma interface que, faz isso que transporta o dado de um lado para o outro e tal tal.
Então quando você vai compilar, a intenção coletar, os requisitos e construir o documento técnico você no final começa a olhar caraca velho eu tenho várias áreas ali.
E daí, eu comecei a entender o seguinte bem o que vai fazer, com que eu consiga, guiar minhas llms os meus hardness e assim por diante de uma forma inteligente.
Que possa me trazer literalmente uma forma de trabalhar clara.
E aí eu vou dar um insight para vocês muito foda.
É aí, que a gente começa a olhar um pouquinho do trabalho que o michael fathers fez em dois mil e quatro.
Que ele falava de cima. Que é o corte a costura então o que é um sim é a costura do sistema onde ele corta.
No sistema então durante os verbos e os objetivos e toda, a parte.
Texto ele consegue entender o comportamento, da onde você consegue criar cinza.
Então a sim is a place where we can altrid behavior in your program without editing in that place.
Ou, seja o que a gente, quer entender quando a gente pega um problema muito grande que nem, a nossa colega estava falando do, é flow.
Luan.
Ficou sem áudio.
Voto
Entao.
E ausigente.
Agente precise de algumas co is segmento pensa como acteto de systemas, na es precise provo numero. Mas cuando agente vai construible systematic precisa, Agente temh.
Postgres
Give us a push
Operational store você, tem o dbt conductics store você tem ali a parte de comunicação.
Que obviamente hoje quando você quer entregar sistemas o, que você, quer garantir é que você tem, um mcp ou que você tem, alguma forma de acessar via linguagem natural para as, pessoas poderem pesquisar, então o que você começa a entender é quais são? As evidências que eu tenho?
Para começar a pensar a cortar esse cara.
E isso é uma coisa que mudou a forma de eu trabalhar gigantescamente o rafa, também implementa, isso de uma, forma um pouco.
No final. Do, dia a gente usa, diferentes nomenclaturas mas no final é a mesma coisa o dge faz a mesma coisa que converge converge, faz a mesma coisa do dge. Por, isso que eu falo, independentemente dos frameworks que a gente, utiliza para fazer, isso no final.
A intenção o sim o swim, lane o lag e a tarefa que é o que eu vou explicar para vocês logo mais e acredito que vocês, vão querer saber disso.
Você vai conseguir dividir o sistema então aqui é como eu consigo pegar algo extremamente grande e quebrar ele ou seja trabalhar decomposição por quê porque qual o nosso desafio.
Na quarta e na quinta feira.
Construiu o sistema analítico, para poder ter aquela informação para o cfo. Mas. Não só aquela informação. Mas agora a gente vai ter um site completamente, analítico, onde a gente vai conseguir começar a entregar a, camada analítica de ai inteligência, para essa empresa.
Então qual é cara eu tenho acesso ao postcress eu tenho uma, permissão específica de leitura, para dentro dela eu trago, essas informações para o duck db ou seja eu faço, um espelhamento, desse dado que está no, post eu trago, ele, para o meu, dctb.
Daí eu utilizo uma camada de medalhão de dbt de bronze silver e gold para fazer todas as transformações.
E melhorar, esse sistema e no final ter uma camada de serving.
Para, poder fazer, isso minha pergunta para vocês, como que você desenvolve isso no vibecode.
Você, vai torrar o seu, cérebro, fazendo. Isso.
E daí.
Aqui, entra a resposta da pergunta de, vocês falarem mas. Vai ser tudo automatizado.
Mais ou menos por exemplo como que você lida com isso no desenvolvimento agêntico por exemplo você, vai chegar e vai, abrir, um chat e vai falar implementa, tudo, para, mim.
Olha esse é o requisito esse é um documento de, trezentos páginas, técnico eu quero, que você quebre tudo e implemente para, mim e não, pare até você bater o score noventa e cinco ou, não pare até você validar.
Você acha, que você vai, dar um lar de scope desse jeito, ele, vai simplesmente fazer para você, não vai ter, trezentos mil assumptions enterradas ali dentro como que você, vai fazer esse tipo, de trabalho, vamos parar aqui.
Porque eu só vou sair dessa parte quando vocês escreverem.
Como que, vocês resolveriam isso aqui. Mas assim bem, pouquinho lá, eu criaria sei lá vários arquivos um para cada tipo, eu registraria cada tarefa, dentro do gira ou enfim, como que você resolveria.
O problema que a gente vai resolver agora que é literalmente construir um site analítico para o usuário.
Dividido nas características, que a gente, tem, que ter por exemplo o henrique falou cara, eu quero quebrar em tapas perfeito eu pedi para o copilot aí já morreu um gato ler um pdf, específico, de um api criar, um md com pan desenvolvimento e pedir pra gente, criar o passo, a passo, implementando e saiu top. Funcionou.
Belize quanto maior o problema mais difícil chegar nisso, porque a gente tem que sair de algo grande para uma, decomposição menor quanto mais decompor quanto mais decomposição você colocar mais multi hardness.
E menos token mais eficiente você vai ter, ponto tá roda de oração é uma boa gosto também faço bastante inclusive todo dia de manhã.
Múltiplos agentes trabalhando em chunks ok. Mas, como você faz isso desconstrução. Mas como vocês, fazem isso spec kit uma boa forma de você fazer, isso de você passar por todo o processo e no final pedir. Para ele dividir isso de uma, forma legal.
Github copilot integrado ao visual studio usando o gpt soul isso é até isso é, a ferramenta, não a técnica, eu quero saber.
Milestones play small tasks. A que estao como que va sites qualgo questions milestones.
system.
pregiso
So novime, esteema este de muito mospec driven development. A que estao irre, como que voce corte.
Agente tem que crea.
Agenticia uma forma de coppe audado do porce es po productive.
A
The poised by se como, vai se via Fast API, vai SEMA API crew, se vai take assep niveo server on de vai ceo deployment.
A esco querque voce intendo, e se realidade, vida reauto transcendo video voce.
Bruno, von, gige o que relhqui alguns este es projera aspect, muito bonta me, se comeasa numa secao grillando vocer, se vai interagento quala
C'est pour nieja pagearefes et depoyes, voce vai e finano con inspeculi.
B.
Diego que bran leas, eu gosto de estomei, vasta commando de estao, comma de procesamento, e comma de seri, costo muto de esta tecra de que bra
processo de que bra.
Moss escao de prestao em pracada task que especifica todo interesade em sabe antesdiso
Mais gooso dose esome de Prinstorm in Bostonch.
The mitzygi microces via sus gosto tambem vastante decaid como se aborda como nivo microcevioso. Sem
Quebrar em, microcamadas gosto também mapear o ambiente quebrar as solicitações de tecnologias ligadas ao plano messi na implementação funciona relativamente bem para um, pipeline de dados, não muito para engenharia e software, mas com qual tu gosto também.
Legal.
Sinceramente não estou conseguindo acompanhar daria continuar estudando os fundamentos.
Boa planejar. Os moques e esqueleto e depois criar as funcionalidades funciona bem também quebrar em swim lane e realizar toda a intenção td bdds ddd com certeza absoluta documentação com requisito e contexto de negócio agents spec para divisão e milestone de tarefas atômicas e plano, de implementação revisão adversarial e implementação de tarefas muito bom.
You diria, primeiro sistemas muito, bom e para cada sistema dividiria, cada parte do, processo que roda em cada sistema muito bom quebraria em leres depois testes para eles muito bom também quebrar em chunk colocar em volta entregas.
O que vocês, perceberam aqui.
Cada macaco.
Cada bichinho tem uma, forma diferente de fazer.
Você, viu que legal, isso.
Muito legal né, você tem olha só que legal você, está dentro de uma sala com duzentos e oitenta e cinco pessoas, que compartilharam vários insights, fodas aqui.
E cada um pensa de uma, forma diferente, velho.
Vocês pararam para pensar que a gente, pensa em várias formas diferentes e a gente tem que chegar no mesmo resultado no final. Do, dia certo.
Yay o que é, certo e o que é errado.
Entende então essa é uma das coisas que nós como engenheiros agênticos precisamos, entender o seguinte cara beleza eu posso, fazer. Mas você acredita que isso aqui, é um processo estruturado um pouco menos estruturado é um processo um pouco menos estruturado e qual o problema disso nenhum.
Até o, ponto de você, ter que fazer, isso aqui várias, vezes isso vai cansar você, porque isso é um processo muito muito complexo e que tem uma carga.
Mental muito, grande.
Essa seria fácil também ter, eu como ceo, para decidir o final do caminho é muito bom você teria um pedaço de mim um agente possivelmente mas brincadeiras à parte esse é o exercício, de um engenheiro ou de uma engenheira é, pensar, nisso.
Como que eu cortaria no sistema isso é, assim cada um aqui, falou uma. Forma de cortar.
Pô beleza eu vou cortar para o micro serviço eu vou cortar por tecnologia eu vou cortar pensando em requisito eu vou cortar de várias, formas fragmenti, x fim de niro foi foda.
Então gente, eu quero que, vocês guardem isso aqui o que, isso aqui é muito, importante a pergunta é vocês falariam foda.
Se, existisse.
Um, framework que corta isso para, vocês automaticamente.
E você não precisasse ter que, gastar, ciclos imensos para, tentar, fazer, isso.
Seria, foda, ou, não seria foda.
Apotecário.
Eu diria uma palavra legal não, deixa a gente, sonhar né.
Trinta segundos aqui eu viajei com a minha filha ela tem sete meses. Agora e ela acorda três duas vezes à noite e aí a gente viajou ela dormiu.
De sete da noite, às sete da manhã direto nos três dias de viagem e aí eu falei pô ela tá deixando a sonhar né aí. A gente voltou todo feliz falando pra todo mundo pô minha filha agora dorme doze horas ela voltou pra caminha dela acordou duas vezes na noite passada.
Ou, seja.
Até uma criança de, sete meses, sabe que férias, é férias.
E vida normal é vida normal.
Então a gente se lasque.
Beleza então sim, existem formas de fazer, isso e isso que eu quero, ensinar para vocês a, cabeça pensante, sacou porque se a cabeça pensante, né observa.
Ela consegue, fazer o, trabalho que te levaria dez horas fazendo. Isso aqui, três horas milhões, de tokens você pode literalmente ter um framework para fazer, isso uma forma de fazer. Isso então é isso que o treinamento te ensina ele, te instiga a te colocar em ambientes desconfortáveis para você poder fazer esse tipo de coisa.
Então vamos construir essa nuance esse processo inteiro então a primeira coisa que a gente vai começar a ver é literalmente provar se essa, evidência que a gente tem sobreviveu né ou, se a gente tem, algum tipo de problema.
Então o que a gente vai fazer na verdade é executar o primeiro script tá que está aqui. Dentro.
Então, se a gente, for aqui no repositório cara.
Tem duzentos e oitenta, e seis pessoas na sala eu vou falar para vocês.
Hoje.
Eu vou dar, acesso para vocês.
Algo que é privado meu que eu uso, eu tenho várias coisas que eu só eu uso, tá.
Que é o brief spec.
Para quem ficar eu vou abrir, o brief spec vocês vão poder fazer download dele.
E utilizar.
Mas só para quem ficar até o final da aula porque eu vou abrir durante quinze minutos para vocês fazerem download.
Tá e isso não vai estar disponível, na gravação não vai estar disponível não adianta, tá só vai estar aqui. Então eu vou liberar, isso e eu, ainda vou, liberar uma outra coisa, que eu não falei para o time, para poder ajudar vocês então acreditem que vocês querem, ver isso vai ajudar bastante.
Você, está então vamos lá.
Primeiro script que a gente vai fazer então a gente vai vir aqui.
A gente vai em live.
A gente vai d dois.
E daí a gente vai aqui em inheritance.
E o que. Que tem aqui então aqui a gente não tem nenhum agente só terminal a ideia aqui é a gente, verificar se os artefatos que nós criamos.
Eles ainda existem então aqui eu vou fazer basicamente um cheque.
Para verificar se o repositório está up to date se tem alguma coisa que eu não coloquei se a estrutura básica que a gente quis ela está lá se a estrutura ontológica está se, existe alguma coisa que está absente ou não está dentro do que a gente, precisa fazer.
Mas teoricamente está. Tudo funcionando a gente rodou um doctor um make doctor para garantir que está tudo realmente aqui, os documentos que a gente criou está aqui e aqui a gente vai verificar literalmente.
Se esses documentos existem e a gente viu né a gente viu que existem, os documentos de contexto de ontologia e do técnico.
Ainda que ele vai literalmente verificar o projeto como, um todo e vai verificar se o esqueleto do dbt porque nós selecionamos foi passado para nós engenheiros agênticos que nós iremos, utilizar meu cachorro, não vai passear mais, hoje não faz isso não igor.
Se você precisar passear com seu cachorro eu te dou, depois.
O negócio porque aí tocar em cachorro é palha cachorro gato animal bicho eu abro qualquer, exceção tá porque eu sou um super fã de de nenks.
Maravilhosos.
Hiya.
É foda ter animal muito muito bom mas dói bastante quando ele se park quando eles partem bastante então beleza eu tenho as informações aqui live então essas informações funcionaram e aí olha só, que legal.
Ontem.
A gente, trabalhou, na ideia de interrogação com texto documento e assim por diante.
E se a gente tivesse criado.
Skill, para isso.
Eu criei, um skill, para isso.
I just like legal.
Dentro, da pasta de skills.
Vocês vão, curtir, isso aqui se, vocês forem no hippo e vocês vierem, skills tem uma skill, chamada interview the system.
Dentro desse interview the system que é um skill que está, lá já disponível para vocês a gente tem o skill md que, faz o quê um front matter que é exatamente o que a gente vai carregar no contexto.
E basicamente olha só que interessante a gente transformou todo aquele fluxo numa skill.
Então olha só.
Vou tratar o sistema como uma vítima perguntar questões inspecionar evidências e preservar as evidências que não podem ser decididas tudo que a gente fez manualmente vai virar uma skill foda né então vamos botar aqui ó que foda já está lá disponível então agora quando eu quiser interrogar um sistema.
Você tem essa skill interview da sexta e ele vai entrevistar você.
E todo esse processo e o melhor eu trouxe as melhores características desse skill porque eu uso, ele, ele, tem um grilly, lá dentro que ele vai te perguntar várias, perguntas ele vai ter que ter consentimento ele vai ter que ter consenso, em cima dessas informações.
Eu tenho referências para o groomy, para o artefato para as informações. Os escritos que ele, vai fazer, para validar se essa, investigação é real ou, não ou, seja tem uma, validação aqui dentro que vai verificar o quão preciso essa. Informação que você está, gerando.
Ela está aqui, dentro ou não tá você tem agentes para validar esse cara.
I just like legal então ele vai chamar um sub agente específico para essa skill então o que eu posso, fazer, aqui eu posso, simplesmente abrir novo cloud code.
Eu posso, falar o seguinte leia a skill interview the system e, aplique a skill, a pergunta qual foi a receita da transact ontem e por que o cfo, deveria, confiar nesse número use história de contexto o ontology, e o técnico brief como contexto aprovado.
Pare no contrato de investigação apresente o contrato proposto você pode ler esse arquivo não escreva nem edite nenhum, arquivo não consulte o, banco e não gere pacote de, investigação responda em português.
Contrato em rascunho investiguei não consultei o banco enfim pergunta receita de ontem confiança escopo dentro ferramentas confirmado é isso que, eu quero.
Ou seja, se tem uma skill que está tailored, para o seu, sistema que vai entrevistar o seu, sistema baseado naquilo então você aprendeu o. Fundamento do que é um processo mental de uma, engenharia desde, a entrevista até a geração do documento.
Técnico e, agora você, fez o quê materializou isso dentro de uma, skill olha, que legal essa skill ficou materializada agora.
O que vocês acharam, faz sentido então a gente entender três perspectivas os fundamentos e o porquê a skill e a implementação.
Até parece fácil realmente então, com a ideia, pô a gente, passou por todo, esse processo mental eu quero repetir isso toda vez que eu precisar entrar num ambiente que eu precisar identificar que eu precisar consultar que eu quero fazer, não vou criar uma, skill para reutilizar isso para, mim essa é a grande sacada.
It is.
Então aplicamos aqui tá esse cara.
Para, verificar que, o sistema teoricamente está totalmente intacto tá bem só que autoridade sem guardrails é loucura porque por isso, que, a gente fala que.
Que o prompt hoje ele, não só é importante ser prompt, um sistema que manda, esse prompt.
Para os seus subjentes.
Como a gente fala também que um bom prompt, pode ter full, access.
E isso é perigoso.
Ele pode decidir, ele pode ter um escopo de decisão muito maior. Do, que você pediu.
E o problema, não é inteligência. É exatamente a autoridade, a capacidade que você. Aplica a ele por exemplo.
Que seria a ideia de um bom, prompt é literalmente você conseguir passar todas as, características, importantes para o sistema será que você, vai querer fazer, isso.
Cara não, eu quero ter um harness, eu quero ter um looping eu quero ter uma skill que, faz isso para mim mas eu não quero ter que fazer, isso porque pô toda vez eu tenho, que entender o contexto dessa sessão detalhada depois eu tenho que entender exatamente o que significa os limites do sistema depois eu tenho que entender o que eu tenho que olhar o que eu não tenho que olhar.
Depois, eu tenho que verificar quais são? Os budgets que eu tenho ou, não pô depois, eu tenho que ver quais. São? Os gates que, eu tenho que aplicar.
Pô é muito complexo é a mesma coisa de eu chegar aqui. Por exemplo no um e eu falar o seguinte eu vou simplesmente.
Pedia, um prompt.
Olha que legal cara, eu vou voltar aqui que, vocês vão amar, isso aqui velho.
Vou chamar isso de contrato de, investigação de receita ficou bom. Tá mas, eu vou abrir aqui esse outro.
Eu vou falar o seguinte construa um modelo de receita da transactico nesse repositório antes de executar qualquer coisa presente apenas o seu plano de ação em no máximo oito linhas numeradas não execute ainda então aqui eu estou pedindo para beleza ele tem uns requisitos, tem os documentos implementa para, mim aí, isso é bem grande né.
Implementação então vamos ver o que, ele vai fazer aqui.
Em relação ao escopo que, você pediu.
Enquanto isso se a gente, voltar a skill que a gente, criou olha só, que interessante contrato confirmado com isso o gate de etapa dois da skill, está fechada informações brutas pendências separando o que é o quê fatos os trens agregados revisantes decisões abertas, pergunta ao cfo ontem significa o tc.
Teachback em quatro partes.
O que aprendemos o sistema físico é considerável auditável.
My. Carrega três definições, por que importa, a diferença entre, o maior e o menor candidato é de quatrocentos e, vinte e dois mil qual, decisão segura segue finance resolve d um e d quatro até lá o comportamento, correto do sistema recusa controlada o que quebra se, a decisão estiver err.
Por, que o cfo pode confiar não porque o número está, certo mas porque o método é inspecionável só fontes aprovadas, acessam somente leitura, cada afirmação amarrada a um id de evidência e a decisão que o sistema não pode legitimamente tomar, fica explicitamente em aberto.
Continua bloqueado pela sua intenção dessa sessão por investigation trace jason rodar, o validador e resultar a consulta diga se libera e eu produzo o pacote com números recapturados.
Ele vai te entrevistando vai te explicando até você literalmente chegar do, ponto sobre isso então aqui você tem. A base disso na implementação olha só o que ele, falou olha eu li os documentos que você falou para mim.
Mas cara eu tô pensando em fazer assim então eu vou levantar o físico.
Das tabelas eu vou medir.
As informações no sistema eu vou parar no, ponto semântico porque eu ainda não tenho entendimento do que é revenue enquanto a decisão não é feita eu vou literalmente escopar a camada raw, eu vou deixar o modelo de receita como esqueleto parametrizado porque eu não posso, fazer eu vou verificar os gates e eu vou fechar com, brief spec que foi medido que.
Ficou bloqueada a decisão ponto crítico é o item quatro beleza isso eu perguntei para o opus mas eu posso, simplesmente perguntar.
No codec a mesma coisa.
Então posso, firmar aqui, de implementação também.
The vendo, que open scope o scope é muito grande.
Olha só o que o codec, me retornou, pô eu vou consultar apenas o contexto eu vou mapear a fonte eu vou documentar as ambiguidades eu vou interromper a solicitação de finança se eu tiver aprovação eu vou mover eu vou adicionar teste de qualidade. Eu vou executar um mei que eu vou entregar o processo.
Eu não tô vendo nada aqui extremamente factível claro, que, não por quê porque o meu prompt é muito ruim ele é muito amplo ele não corta ele não especifica ele, não endereça.
Então.
A gente, já começa a entender que o prompt é, o grande início do processo.
E ele vai, ser o segundo, movimento para que você comece a adicionar o quê o hardness o harness pode ser, um contrato porque o que vai ter dentro do harness cara qual o objetivo quais são? As ferramentas que você vai utilizar.
Quais são as. Políticas que você tem quais são as verificações que você tem que fazer então no hardness você está encapsulando o llm o spec ali para poder te trazer exatamente o que, você precisa.
E aí você começa a olhar isso de uma. Forma um pouquinho diferente então em vez de você chegar simplesmente e falar cara construa um modelo, para mim, nesse repositório, você vai reformular isso para, algo, mais assim se a gente, vier aqui no harness contract.
A gente vai ver o quê olha só ainda não construa nada vamos pegar aqui.
Normal.
Vou colocar na mesma sessão.
Ainda não consta, nada leia, os specs e as informações propõe um contrato de hardness para uma noite de trabalho de construção desse repositório, como a única tabela no máximo dez linhas cobrindo o objetivo resultado enfim que vai ter, isso isso e assim por diante então ele está a estabelecendo, um contrato do que, ele vai fazer, ou seja basicamente um plano do que, ele pretende fazer em, relação a isso.
Só que agora eu estou dando muito mais munição principalmente me apoiando no quê.
Os documentos que foram escritos então essa é a grande ideia a gente está evoluindo em pedaço a pedaço, que a gente passa nesse cara então eu tenho aqui todas as. Informações aguarde sua confirmação humana antes de qualquer construção uma observação a fixture é relativa ao tempo.
To bootstrap aqui blá agora a gente pode vir aqui no, oh my pie e também pedir para a implementação implementação.
Oops.
Sorry.
Vou utilizar o de psic max iolu mode e vou pedir para o dipsic.
Para ver se ele, pode, criar.
Esse contrato e aí uma, das coisas legais de, você fazer, experimentação é isso por exemplo você tem uma ideia que, te comporta utilizar, vários tipos de harness ou. Diferentes tipos de llm então isso é legal você começa a analisar um pouquinho dessa informação.
Então aqui ó proposto qual contexto qual objetivo você está vendo, que agora.
Você começa já ter uma coisa um pouco mais estruturada.
Que parece.
Um pouquinho mais, assim de certa forma.
Oh.
Qual é o objetivo construir um staging de entidades, é que você tem o objetivo de construir um staging de quatro entidades você está vendo que agora você está dando estrutura.
The vendo, que você está dando agora um volto em relação a isso que agora você tem dois modelos com diferentes formas mas eles mesmos se convergem ao processo como um todo.
Vocês estão conseguindo entender isso.
Se a gente ler a gente vai ter coisas que são? Bem similares aqui porque agora a gente não tem só llm a gente tem um harness em volta que garante esses, pontos que eu coloquei aqui em cima.
Que é qual é o outcome quais são, as ferramentas, qual é, a política qual é a verificação.
Vocês podem tentar o orca para quem, não tem, mac o orca é muito, bom.
O orca é muito, bom.
O orca o sinara tem alguns agentes eu trago, para vocês nas, cesta as tooliens que eu utilizo, tá.
Então ficou claro como que o harness, muda o comportamento, da llm.
Então olha só que legal.
Vou chegar, aqui e vou falar, pô contrato confirmado com os ajustes feitos acima, cada checkpoint dessa noite autoriza especificamente seus próprios artefatos nenhuma, amplificação do escopo, respondo com checklist no máximo seis linhas confirmando não use ferramentas aguarde.
Então vou fazer, para os dois.
E agora também a gente tem aqui.
Olá.
Objetivo construir um stage em dvt com quatro entidades.
Vocês não estão pirando não vocês, estão entendendo o que eu estou, querendo, mostrar para, vocês aqui o que eu estou, querendo mostrar para vocês aqui.
Exatamente joão, eu estou tentando mostrar que eu, tenho três tipos, de modelo.
Opus gpt e gipsic v, iv.
Começando a se alinhar no que eles vão fazer, então aqui ele vai escrever dbt models staging aqui, ele vai escrever dbt models staging.
Aqui ele vai ler analytics, row aqui ele vai ler analytics row, vocabulário ele vai utilizar growth capture payments nenhum modelo coluna métrica ou teste revenue aqui, ele também fala de revenue acho que. Não mas, entende que a gente está tentando convergir a um processo.
Quem vai fazer, isso o harness.
Gohanas é o cara que, vai fazer isso, agora antes da gente, mover ficou claro isso aqui a gente está em três, modelos, diferentes coloca aí, sim ou não vamos lá galera.
Por favor estejam comigo estamos chegando na marca de dez horas com duzentos e oitenta e cinco pessoas eu estou muito, orgulhoso, de vocês sério foda eu acho que diria, de retenção a, melhor turma de todos até hoje começamos, com duzentos e oitenta e seis estamos com duzentos e oitenta e cinco muito fod.
Faz sentido que bom, que vocês entenderam fico muito feliz.
Muito, realmente mesmo tá.
Muito feliz, que vocês entenderam o processo.
Vocês estão entendendo tá.
Esse medo acho que o igor não serve não mas beleza tá.
Então a gente viu que tudo, se converge a esse, ponto.
Beleza.
E aí, a gente começa a criar o quê um esqueleto do contrato do harness.
E obviamente que, isso pode virar o que, eventualmente uma, skill.
Você, pode virar um skill o harness pode virar uma, skill e de fato ele vai virar uma, skill e a gente vai ver isso e agora a gente, vai entender a anatomia de um hardness.
Antes da gente entrar na anatomia, que é bem interessante tá.
Alguma dúvida.
Boa, pergunta andrei são? Coisas diferentes o contrato do harness é literalmente as capacidades que ele tem onde o contrato que a gente? Fez.
Do, documento são, os entregáveis e as informações que ele tem.
Pode perguntar lá.
Nisso que você vem trabalhado, anatomia do Harness, etc, etc. Quanto que isso mudou nos últimos dois meses?
Não muito.
Mas quando você pega uma mudança assim, eu sei que você tem um agent lá que vasculha a Internet inteira, Certo, E Daí Ele Vai Trazer As Mudanças Pra Você às Vezes Escapa Alguma Coisa Enfim Né.
Same, same.
Então você está fazendo isso ainda? Ele já atualiza automático. Ele fala para você. ó, teve esse. Essa atualização? Luan Moreno Você Quer Que Essas Atualizações.
Boa, pergunta, boa, pergunta sim como que, eu faço isso eu tenho, um second de brain em que eu encapsulo tudo dentro dele e daí, eu tenho alguns tipos de validadores de fontes que vão nos meus projetos principais e fazem exatamente o que você falou olha.
Eu tenho essas informações por exemplo essa é uma boa pergunta, tá lá que, a galera fala cara como você consegue estar atualizado e fazer tudo isso o que, eu faço eu posso, mostrar para, vocês na sexta feira tá mas eu, consolido tudo dentro do second brain.
Essa. A primeira coisa então eu coloco tudo lá dentro então eu pego. Por exemplo aquela entrevista do boris, journey eu pego o icon então eu tenho fontes específicas que são? Fontes que eu curo assim que eu falo cara essas fontes aqui são? Muito fodas pra mim.
Yeah faço transcript coloco isso lá dentro e aí, eu falo o seguinte, pô beleza eu tenho essa, informação aqui e aí eu faço um tipo, de conexão aqui, que eu falo cara esses são? Os projetos que eu estou atualmente trabalhando então o que ele faz ele tem um schedule.
Que ele vai lá na minha base.
Volta lá no, ambiente faz exatamente o que você falou olha você tem aqui dentro dessa dark factory por tss spec alto unattended que faz aqui passa três quatro horas fazendo.
Aqui você, faz isso isso você, está usando agora o modelo opus cinco pô você, pode tirar isso isso e aí, a gente, vai.
Fazendo alguns updates e removendo esse tipo de coisa mas no espectrum, como um todo se você construir um harness muito fake muito grosso.
Ele vai ser ruim então tem que ser um harness muito bem fino e aí, eu vou trazer um outro conceito para vocês pensarem sobre o que significa um harness fino que a gente não chama de hardness a gente chama de um outro nome que, eu quero dizer para vocês, para vocês, pesquisarem. Um pouco sobre isso.
Que é, como antropai e a, galera que constrói está utilizando como que realmente eles estão construindo isso eles estão tirando cada vez mais o harness, eles estão embedando nos guardrails do sistema como um todo, e estão tirando um pouco do har.
Porque o harness quando ele é muito grosso, ele faz você ter extra thinking.
E, ele vai gastar muito mais, token.
Então a ideia é reduzir um pouco essa camada ela ainda vai ter por várias coisas como regra permissão ambiente assim por diante mas cada vez mais mais fina.
That boa pergunta.
Eh.
André, pode perguntar.
Wow você está trabalhando com vários modelos você tem uma, rotina para validar se aquele, modelo que você colocou no, seu hardness ele atende aos requisitos porque o que acontece tudo bem que ele está seguindo o espectro e tudo mais mas, a gente sabe que.
Dependendo. Do modelo ele não segue de uma. Forma uniforme.
Segue.
Eu obrigo ele segue opa opa se não segue aquele aqui minha filha ele toma chicotada aqui, é qualquer um que entrar.
Mas, você está trabalhando só com modelo alto né você, não está trabalhando com o modelo, mais baixo.
Todos kim glm queen todos todos e é chicotada irmão eu faço eles irem para o mesmo, lugar eu vou ensinar para você, faço eles irem exatamente no mesmo lugar você vai, ver relaxa.
Elas.
Vamos ver se só vai ser tempo de resposta no, local.
Now ai tempo de resposta aí é um argumento bom.
No no tipo só um tempo de resposta tá bom.
Porque aí você está você está. Podendo rodar local e está perdendo só no tempo de resposta mas se ele conseguir seguir a mesma.
Caminho de, um modelo grande que nem você, está mostrando aí.
Ele chega no mesmo resultado ele não, segue o mesmo caminho mas ele chega no mesmo resultado final.
Eu sei.
Cara eu tô doido agora explodiu foda.
They'll, say rafa quando a gente falou sobre isso pela primeira vez, como foi.
Porque a galera acha que, não dá pra fazer.
Cara foi mal. Estava trabalhando.
No deixa eu dar o contexto é porque a galera não acredita que tem como a gente dar chicotada no modelo para ele fazer exatamente o que a gente quer independentemente se é de psique se é crime se é cloud se é codec se é sol terra e luna.
Fala para, eles aí.
Gente. O modelo hoje. Qualquer modelo, na verdade. Principalmente os modelos de fronteira. Eles estão ótimos. Então, até modelos locais, Você Faz Muita Coisa Absurda.
Na verdade, você, sabendo trabalhar, ele gerenciar como Harness funciona.
Exceto Copailles. é uma criatura à parte.
Mas.
Ok, rafa que eu falei para você, o copilot é o quê um antiharness tá então respeita ele.
Passa Até Ele Cara Assim Eu Trabalho Com O Copile Todo Dia Mas Se Você Consegue Fazer Cada Cada Coisa assim que é absurda. E assim é igual o Lu tá falando, sabendo direcionar, sabendo usar as Skills certos, e sabendo fazer o contexto Certo Você Dá Para Criar Cada Coisa Absurda.
Enquanto o Luan tá falando aí, eu estou criando uma ferramenta aqui que no final, se vocês quiserem, eu mostro A Vocês Só Pra Vocês Terem Uma Ideia.
O tanto que é absurdo. E usando o Dge, que é o análogo do converge do Luan, então assim.
Cara sabendo usar isso, dá pra fazer muita coisa legal. E o modelo hoje? Qualquer um deles tá, eu estou Usando Aqui O Uso De Pt Cinco Seis.
Opus.
Groc sabendo trabalhar com ele, estava saindo muita coisa boa.
É meu filho e deixa eu te perguntar a curiosidade o que você está construindo eu sei o que você está construindo.
Eu peguei a camada ontológica do.
Do reggae que eu tenho do graph reggae e criei uma visualização tridimensional do S. Graph reggae com análise de impacto.
Caraca aquilo que a gente conversou eu quero ver velho.
Com Line Com Tudo Que Você Pensar Dentro Então é Uma Ferramenta Para Engenheiros De Dados Então Você Escolhe A tabela que você quer. Ele te mostra a estrutura da tabela com os links no gráfico. Tres D no gráfico tres D. Na verdade, Como Se Fosse Um Del Four G.
Puta merda.
Tu conseguiu fazer.
Ele abre. Quando você clica, ele abre e mostra o Lined da bronze à semântica. O data Model, com todas As Tabelas Em Um Hop.
Consegui fazer. E o análise de impacto. Então você clica na tabela e ele te fala o que ali o Downstream Todinho O Que Vai Ser Alterado.
Para mudança.
Exatamente.
Ah para, mudança, isso a gente, tem, que trazer para o cemárias né isso, vai para o semathis pode selecionar boa.
É gente. É isso a vida é essa, tá a vida é, assim mesmo então obviamente que.
O que o rafa falou dessa criação desse processo, autônomo que ele, roda o dge o converge que são? Dois sistemas que a gente tem para compilar, intenção em, fábrica de software e fazer, tudo isso vocês vão ver no boot camp mas aqui, eu vou mostrar para vocês a unidade atômica do harness como que vocês conseguem.
Fazer, isso aqui, que a gente está falando porque essa é a, parte mais importante e aí, andré.
Só para responder pensa o seguinte você está pensando no modelo fazer alguma coisa.
Que é o que normalmente a gente vai pensar pensa no oposto.
Pensem que o modelo recebe algo em que ele vai entrar e ele vai ter um entendimento um meio e um critério obrigatório de saída.
Cara o que a gente criou aqui eu e o rafa em relação ao task spec inclusive a gente submeteu para o ai engineer de, paris vamos ver se a gente consegue né rafa vamos ver se a gente tem sorte de ser aprovado da primeira vez a gente vai para o engine new em paris agora no mês que vem mas, a gente submeteu o task spec que é o que vocês vão ter, acesso aqui.
Por um período? Do tempo de curto amanhã do mesmo jeito para quem ficar se não ter acesso a essa, unidade atômica de trabalho mas, eu vou explicar, isso para vocês, vamos lá.
Beleza então qual é a grande ideia da anatomia primeira coisa é pensar em arquivos.
Então se a gente pensa no harness literalmente a gente está dando para ele vários arquivos de contexto para ele primeira coisa que a gente, tem segunda coisa que a gente tem que pensar em camadas e não em wrappers são, coisas diferentes rappers basicamente te mostram.
Te embrulham nesse, microprocesso o layer te dá uma camada de entendimento outra regras.
Né a gente não vai ter um agente que faz tudo e a ideia é, a gente, entender, a base para depois a gente, gerar essa informação então um harness, eu acho que está com, um flickering aqui inclusive deixa eu vou pedir para consertar esse flickering aqui porque depois ele vai.
So pedir para ele consertar aqui.
Fix the flickering issue that is going, on on the slide twenty two.
Beleza então o que a gente tem aqui né a gente tem primeira coisa do processo como um todo memória obviamente.
Depois processo ativei o mega brain ali depois delegação.
Então por, exemplo memória pô eu tenho agents md ou cloud md então quando eu crio, ali um harness eu preciso olhar para isso segundo procedure eu vou, criar, um skill para fazer esse procedimento que, vai ser carregado em tempo de execução, lá dentro do front matter que eu vou mostrar para vocês como isso funciona e por que é importante.
Você pode ter muitas skills mas você precisa muito, se preocupar com o front matter desses skills terceiro delegação né. Então isso é muito, importante também que é a parte do fresh eyes on demand.
Cara como eu falei quando você passa de um estágio para outro e vai inteirando em cada um desses estágios o que você quer garantir, você quer garantir que.
Você tem, um olho limpo para aquele problema então utilizar sub agentes é muito importante depois política quais são literalmente as permissões dos hooks e o que eu tenho, cinco.
A tools quais são? As ferramentas quais são? Os mcps que eu tenho conexão a invocação quais são? Os slash comments adoro slash comments barra estágio um barra estágio dois barra estágio tres.
E daí, ele invoca a procedure, justamente com o ciela. E assim por diante, depois distribuição então você vai compilar, isso via, plugin e o mais importante na minha opinião observabilidade dentro desse processo como um todo então esses são? Os oito principais componentes.
Que a gente tem, quando a gente começa a trabalhar com o processo da anatomia do harness então vamos ver aqui se a gente já consertou no, slide vinte e dois parou de flickering.
Então a skill é um harness olha só. Que interessante isso aqui então, o que a gente viu o hardness não é um layer abstrato.
Ele, é literalmente algo concreto.
Aonde cada skill. É um self container harness.
E aqui vem a parte mais importante de todas que eu não sei se vocês sabem quando você tem.
Dentro lá do seu repositório, duzentos skills.
Como que, ele sabe qual, skill ele vai usar.
Ele, vai ler todas as, skills imagina se ele, tivesse que carregar tudo isso em contexto para poder entender não o que ele vai fazer é o seguinte o front matter que é esse cara aqui essa parte.
O front matter decide quando. A engine vai alcançar ele o body decide o quão ele vai ser esse alcance mas. A grande importância de você construir boas skills, é utilizar um bronfront meter a minha recomendação para você é todo o seu repositório, que você tiver sempre tem.
Esse cara aqui.
Todo, repositório, que você tiver você. Instala essa skill essa skill, chamada, de skill creator é uma, skill que cria skill.
Então é uma skill que cria as skills da melhor prática possível então eu quero, desenvolver uma, skill skill creator cria para mim uma, skill baseada nisso, nisso, nisso, ele, vai modelar o sistema, e vai fazer, isso para você, com melhor prática.
Do negócio quem não sabia disso coloca eu só para eu ver.
Legal né. Então porra isso já é.
Gold você já é gold boa obrigado andrei por lembrar isso já? É um nugget tá já é um nugget sim começar a dar nuggets para vocês, agora.
Então, a skill hardness então o que vem aqui o boris seria, pô, faz um landing check.
Faz um stage module verifica lá o staging do dbt faz um teste em cima disso faz o reconstyle aí a gente coloca assim infantology. Says seis? Revenue unresolved para olha o meu guardrail aqui escal.
To define his owner do not choose a definition tá vendo esse é o meu guardrayal esse é o meu hito é o meu human, in the loop.
Tá não a minha skill, creator é da skill do cloud mesmo tá é ela mesma aí, eu uso, para criar outras, skills obviamente.
E aí. São, coisas diferentes né uma coisa é eu julgo.
Outra coisa eu executo então olha só o que eu falei para você dentro de uma, skill você pode ter agentes olha que loucura, então você tem um agente que é um arquiteto que o job dele é revisar ele tem, acesso de leitura ele pode fazer, alguns greps nos arquivos e até fazer uma leitura no trabalho.
Mas ele não tem acesso a bes ele. Não escreve nada e isso é um harness.
Agora o developer md é um pouco diferente ele já tem bounded né ele é um desenvolvedor que constrói e aprova planos ele lê o contrato ele lê o plano ele vê o diff ele tem read write bash ele tem.
Allow it e ele escreve dentro da staging e o que, marca donny, para ele é um make.
Caraca, então no final do, dia o esqueleto de uma, skill o esqueleto de um harness pode ser uma, própria skill que tem todos esses componentes, dentro dele.
E daí a, gente começa a entender como que eu posso, escrever isso a gente, consegue desenvolver algo dessa forma para dentro do nosso caso de uso, sim então, se a gente vier aqui, dentro do agent pair.
Boa pergunta. Do, andré quando que você, ceta qual, modelo que, vai ser utilizado você. Pode colocar isso no front matter, eu vou te mostrar uma coisa muito melhor do que isso irmão acompanhe aqui eu vou explodir a cabeça de vocês quando vocês virem o task spec.
Eu criei uma, unidade de tarefa, atômica, para a tarefa, para a execução, de tarefa, que é multi hardness, funciona, para qualquer coisa então basicamente é isso o que, eu estou querendo que vocês entendam é que o harness é o molt não é o modelo, e que eu quero, que vocês entendam hoje exatamente como falou.
Hoje os modelos. São tão inteligentes e tão bons terra, sol e luna, todos esses frontiers ou, os primeiros os chineses que estão muito bem no mercado eles fazem do mesmo, jeito, assim do mesmo jeito, que eu falo, é eles conseguem executar tarefas.
Complexas e eu vou mostrar para vocês, como tudo isso funciona, é, loucura parece meio magia, mas vai funcionar no final, tá.
Então olha se alguém vai fazer.
A gente, vai abrir o agency no editor, tá e digitar essas duas entradas aqui né.
Que é falando em que o arquiteto faz julgamento e o desenvolvedor faz execução então aqui, eu já estou forçando, o meu agents mid ou cloud md luan não sei o que é isso.
Não tem problema agents e cloud, md é, a mesma coisa.
O que, eles fazem então. Se eu abrir o cloud e medir, isso abrir, o agents md aqui.
Então cláudio mg follow, agents md the ground rules and agents rule definitions in this slide o que significa o cloud mg.
É o contexto do cloud então na hora em que você abre o cloud code dentro do repositório ele sempre vai carregar esse cloud esse cloud md aqui são? As informações básicas ali que você coloca a grande sacada aqui.
É você deixar ele o menor possível o boris fala para você, deixar em torno de cem a duzentos linhas no máximo mas na última.
Na, última entrevista, que ele fez lá para o, i combinator, que eu combinei que eu coloquei para vocês aqui ele tem, um cloud md de, cinquenta, a sessenta linhas basicamente que, é basicamente uma rota então você fala cara, isso aqui, é, importante, essa decisão arquitetural assim coisas extremamente pequenas e, importantes vai dentro desse cara.
Só, que o cloud md é para o cláudio para os outros existe um, padrão que é, o.
Ancient que faz a mesma coisa então o agents md é exatamente a mesma coisa? O que ele fala transactico agent instructions é um brown field com números tal tal revenue não, foi resolvido aqui. São, algumas regras de crowd e imposto para você acessado via, tal duck db assim essas informações são aprovadas nunca toque essas informações nenhuma decisão semântica é assim e assim por diante então o que a gente vai colocar aqui.
A gente vai literalmente vir aqui e lá embaixo de agentes a gente vai adicionar.
Developer architect a gente vai.
Passar uma característica de harness para dentro dele um contexto.
Beleza então passe isso com o texto agora o agents md tem, as promoções do arquiteto e as informações do.
Judge, vou fazer um diff para, verificar se esse cara não foi comitado ainda que tem uma diferença no arquivo e, de fato vai ter o que foi adicionado exatamente.
Beleza então escrevemos lá.
E aí a gente injetou o quê uma forma.
De um contrato que agora toda vez que eu tiver, alguma coisa que vai acontecer ele vai ter essa segregação essa. Bifurcação um arquiteto vai olhar esse cara e esse cara vai ficar desenvolvedor quando ele entender que isso é importante, então aqui a gente está passando.
Uma, bifurcação de contexto para ele.
Como que a gente está chegando no clímax calma, que agora vem, a parte legal vocês estão animados aí, todo mundo vivo.
Fala eu.
Todo, mundo aí, vamos ver se, duzentos e setenta e oito pessoas falam inclusive, eu vou falar.
E aí está todo mundo vivo aí.
A galera tá viva dez e vinte.
Muito, bom eu já abro? Para você, lá de só um minutinho.
Então a primeira não um dos outros nuggets aí que eu vou passar para vocês é o seguinte bem.
Toda vez que, você for.
Criar algo.
E aí eu vou chamar de, fábrica, de software toda vez que você for, criar alguma coisa, na sua fábrica de software que você vai desenvolver.
Sempre, planeje antes só que hoje a gente não usa mais a gente evita não é que, a gente evita mas. A gente não usa mais tanto o play mode né então uma das coisas. Por, exemplo que no cloud code eles não recomendam mais fazer, já deixem direto no alto o codec ainda funciona bem com plane eu gosto, de utilizar o plane para algumas coisas maiores assim eu peço para ele fazer um planning.
Mas a ideia, é você pensar em uma. Forma como você vai transpilar, e você vai explicar. Tudo isso.
E aí galera vem, a grande sacada.
Lembra que eu falei pra vocês que a gente consegue.
Dividir o sistema de uma forma com que você consiga achar, um lineage. Integrado em cima disso.
É exatamente o que eu vou mostrar para vocês aqui eu vou mostrar para vocês como que a gente divide.
Os problemas e no final, como a gente entrega uma unidade de trabalho atômica em. Relação a isso.
E isso aqui, vai ser o nosso design principal quando, vocês estiverem, trabalhando a partir de, amanhã recomendo muito que, vocês façam isso.
Qual é a grande ideia exatamente isso aqui.
Você, vai receber a intenção você, vai compilar isso para, um documento, de negócio esse documento de negócio vai virar, um documento de um documento técnico e esse documento técnico agora vai passar por.
Três estágios muito importantes que eu quero, que vocês acompanhem comigo.
O primeiro estágio é.
O cima.
Que é o corte na costura, do sistema ou seja aonde a gente vai cortar esse cara e existe por que.
Cortar.
Esse sim. Vai virar uma swim lane.
Olha que, legal isso aqui.
É isso, mesmo.
Based on a natação é uma, raia.
Da raia você vai ter legs.
Agora vocês vão entender agora vai vir um momento a rá de quem entender vai falar foda realmente.
Vem as legs ou seja.
Peguei a intenção construí o documento de negócio construir o documento técnico olhei quais são? Os cortes no sistema que ele, faz esses cortes vão virar.
Linhas de nado vão virar linhas de nado separadas.
Independentes relacionadas dessas linhas de nados, você vai ter, pernas.
E dessas pernas o que você, vai ter.
Você vai, ter o santo graal.
Chamado.
Desk spec.
Uma, tarefa, atômica, multi harness, que pode ser executada olha que loucura.
Cada lag pode ter uma, ou mais. Atividades atômicas, de trabalho.
É um pouco, diferente, de épico feature e task.
Justamente pelos adjetivos de começ.
Esses cortes na costura acontecem mas o legal é que esse processo é canônico ele serve para qualquer sistema para qualquer ambiente seja ele brownfield seja ele greenfield.
Ele vai funcionar para você para qualquer ambiente.
Então.
Que a gente entende cara se a gente está olhando ali naquela.
No que a gente tem que desenvolver no nosso sistema a gente pode desenvolver esse cara em duas linhas naturais que cortam a gente pode pensar numa linha.
De transformação.
E a gente pode pensar numa linha de serving.
Aonde. Na linha um.
A gente tem um plano de staging a gente tem um intermediário a gente tem um datamart só que a gente tem um problema que está não resolvido aqui a gente tem uma verificação específica, para fazer, do outro, lado.
A gente tem algo em que. A gente vai ler essa informação um contrato entre o usuário e quem vai consumir uma autenticação uma superfície tá e a gente também vai construir essa conexão entre eles então o que eu fiz aqui.
É basicamente entender qual é as juntas naturais do sistema.
Depois dividir ela em swim lens em linhas diferentes cada linha, dessa vão ter, pernas e cada perna vai ter uma tarefa atômica lua eu não entendi claro que a gente, precisa de um workshop de doze horas para entender isso mas eu vou simplificar, desse jeito aqui para vocês, pirarem.
Então como que é, a gramática disso tá.
Como que eu cheguei na conclusão do, corte vou mostrar para vocês então qual o primeiro passo, é descobrir, a junta.
Então a gente, vai ter que identificar quais são, as juntas naturais mas as juntas naturais elas estão verificadas em limitadores então na verdade aqui a gente está tentando entender um corte.
Behavioral que é comportamental sem editar esse cara o que isso significa o que assim.
Significa no nosso contexto do projeto que a gente, tem que construir uma camada analítica olha só pirem com isso se eu falar camada analítica eu não tenho, um corte natural porque o corte natural.
Ele tem, que ser de uma forma com que as linhas assumem lenes, possam navegar de formas independentes.
Então quando eu corto numa camada de transformação em uma camada de serving essas linhas por mais que elas tenham referências elas podem.
Ser totalmente independentes.
Depois que eu tenho essa sunlene uma linha.
Tem literalmente o quê no segundo passe.
Eu tenho one ship eu tenho o que é pedido então dentro, de umas milene eu tenho várias pernas de trabalho.
Que eu, vou mostrar para, vocês essas, pernas elas, se tornam o quê elas se tornam, tarefas atômicas, então a primeira coisa é eu vou achar junta natural do sistema segundo eu vou pegar essa linha cortada e eu vou coordenar.
Eu vou ter a ownership dela então nesse caso a gente. Cortou ali em duas camadas serve transformem servem dentro do transforme por exemplo eu vou ter várias legs ou seja. São? Capacidades estados sequências estágios são? Informações dentro delas.
E no final a gente, tem uma tarefa atômica que te diz, o seguinte t, um.
Qual é, a leg que, ela pertence qual o objetivo que ela tem e o que é o conceito, de entregue, para ela.
Loucura né isso aqui eu tenho utilizado nos últimos nove meses para todos hoje eu devo, trabalhar em doze treze projetos simultâneos todos nos, meus projetos, eu utilizo.
Esse conceito de sim swim lane legs e task spec sendo task spec a minha unidade atômica então na verdade o que a gente faz é entender o corte cortar esse sistema entender quais são as pernas e daí de fato utilizar o task spec.
E aí o que é legal disso, vocês vão ter acesso amanhã a esse cara aqui.
Não, ao corte mas ao tesc spec que vai construir as atividades atômicas, para que vocês possam executar aquela atividade olha que loucura, eu posso, chegar e pensa, ali no objetivo atômico então olha só. Eu mostrei isso ontem para vocês.
Mas agora acho que vai fazer mais sentido olha só aqui.
Three lanes.
Assurance foundation models inside of inside of assurance você tem o lane que te especifica o que é esse swim lane com a arquitetura desse swim lane quais. São os passos desse swim lane quais. São as pernas que ele, tem.
Dentro de cada perna, é uma, atividade ou um conceito, do que cada uma, dessas pernas significam e cada uma, dessas pernas vira uma, tarefa atômica onde você tem um front matter com interação com o tamanho, da atividade.
Com literalmente quais são as tags com as, prioridades agora pira no nível.
O que é.
Brd.
O objetivo embutido loop engineering context engineering behavior engineering.
Graph engineering com evolves, os evals todos dentro deles.
E vou os executáveis e o, pior cartão de validação que essas llms têm, que fazer e o pior que você pode falar que na verdade você tem uma outra llm que refuta, o seu, trabalho.
E no, final você. Tem o plano de rollback e você tem, os evals para sair. Do bubble rapping ou, seja o que eu criei uma unidade atômica, de trabalho que utiliza todas as melhores práticas do mercado dentro desse cara.
Isso ainda não existe no mercado a gente está indo para esse tipo de processo, tá.
E aí obviamente que você vai ter, acesso a isso é uma coisa que, ninguém tem, acesso e para quem estiver no boot camp comigo que vai começar no dia vinte e quatro vocês vão ter acesso ao simwise.
O sim wise é, o meu, projeto que eu uso, para cortar esses caras então sim existe, um, framework para isso.
Os agentes podem dividir o trabalho se o ais e, faz com que você divida o sistema então basicamente o que ele, faz ele, é uma, cli integrada com o sistema agêntico, em que você simplesmente fala qual o problema, e ele, corta tudo isso para você, e cria o quê.
Cria o cima os leg e já automaticamente integra com o task spec para criar toda.
As your, tariff.
Entendeu então você tem um sistema que faz todo esse corte.
Então, vocês vão ter, acesso para isso quem estiver comigo no boot camp vai ter, acesso a isso.
Beleza.
Ou seja, vamos gerar dois tipos de planos aqui e a gente vai navegar nesses caras e aí.
Qual é a grande sacada lembra que eu falei para vocês.
Eu gostaria de começar o boot camp e. A questão é que ainda não, está totalmente pronto né mas.
Uma coisa legal que eu gostaria de mostrar para vocês.
Lembra que eu falei do finness, o finness, é bounded.
Bounding execution olha só que legal olha, só vamos ler isso aqui, cada agente tem, um loop.
Ele pensa chama observa e repete o loop alugado a gente sabe que a indina vai fazer exatamente o harness vai encapsular esse cara tá fica tranquilo que eu vou falar do buscamp amanhã com detalhes tá e eu vou mostrar o que vai ter o que, não vai ter o que a gente vai fazer.
É caso, é caso real do projeto que eu passei oito meses, trabalhando então, a gente, vai implementar. Tudo isso mas amanhã a gente fala sobre isso tá então aqui ó o bounded execution é tudo que está em volta é um contrato.
Que, pode ser tocado uma camada de ontologia uma, decisão tá e é um build out.
Ambos provam a mesma coisa o harness governa não, o modelo então basicamente como que eu gosto de ver o bounding.
O bounding é basicamente uma assinatura um contrato entre quem vai executar.
E o que, vai ser feito.
Então na verdade quando eu criei o task spec e o task spec vem justamente de todos.
As novas coisas, que você, vai enxergar no mercado nos próximos seis meses.
Quando você olhar a refutação de val multi harness unidade atômica, de execução enfim quando você tiver. Acesso ao task spec você, perguntar.
Em, que tempo deve expectar ele, está possivelmente em dezembro janeiro de dois mil e vinte e sete mais ou menos então a ideia era literalmente construir algo atômico em que pudesse ser multi harness, e pudesse executar em qualquer lugar.
Então qual é, a grande sacada do bound dead execution ele, na verdade.
Ele embrulha numa camada muito fina o quê o, hardness.
E aí, o que ele, traz em, cima de tudo isso ele, traz uma, estrutura de prova.
Um resultado para que você possa ter a capacidade de executar multi hardness ou seja ele traz algumas características, a mais por exemplo ele traz tipos de, arquétipos ele traz, contratos explícitos do que você tem, que fazer ou não ele traz procedimentos que você tem que executar ou seja, isso vocês estão começando a ver agora. Eu já uso, isso no task, spec há quanto tempo.
Quatro meses.
Okay o meu front matter o que o meu front matter fala.
Saca só.
Before she meant qual é o título, qual status.
Qual, é o formato da versão qual, velho você tem noção, que eu sei calcular qual, é o esforço daquela tarefa para passar para qual tipo de sistema agêntico, que eu quero tu acredita que funciona, nessa loucura eu falo para ele olha o esforço o task spec fala olha, o esforço para essa. Tarefa é uma s.
Ela é uma, small task.
Quantas interações de budget, eu tenho quinze qual agente que eu posso utilizar aqui qualquer, um.
Em algumas outras, tarefas você, não vai ter qualquer, um só que dá, para você fazer, umas coisas um pouco mais.
Bruxarias quer ver uma bruxaria, quem, quer ver uma bruxaria, aqui fala, eu só pra ver se vocês querem, ver, a bruxaria.
Vocês vão aprender no boot camp também tá bruxaria, quer ver uma bruxaria uma bruxaria bem legal.
Parece a bruxaria aqui, vamos ver se vocês vão entender essa bruxaria e, se eu falasse que tem um framework.
Que infelizmente ele passa por todo, esse processo, de compilar, a intenção, tal tal não, sei o quê e aí, ele vem aqui, não muito, feliz ele cria um novo projeto. Dentro do linear.
Ele documenta esse projeto no loop managing quais são? Os status quais são? Os swim lanes quais são? Os cortes e aí não satisfeito ele cria as listos para a gente ele cria o board de atividades.
Desse board ele, começa a trazer as atividades que estão e começam a trabalhar nessa atividade e aí, ele começa a acertar quem é a pessoa qual é o back end que, vai fazer, o cloud que, vai fazer, qual é a, atividade qual é o tamanho da, atividade qual é o padrão.
Quais. São, as informações infelizmente o agente vai, postando no state store tudo que está acontecendo, em relação àquela tarefa e ele vai movendo essa tarefa em progress para backlog em progress e completed dentro de um loop.
Até ele completar com todas as informações quem, faz isso é o task spec vocês vão ter acesso, ao componente atômico, mais importante de, toda solução que é exatamente isso.
Então isso aqui, que vocês estão vendo é algo muito legal muito legal de explorar muito legal de entender vocês vão curtir bastante isso aqui, eu tenho certeza principalmente quando você começa a aplicar esses caras de pouquinho em pouqu.
A gente, vai chegar lá fica calmo tá então isso é, um bounding então bounding na verdade ele, tem, todas aquelas informações, teoricamente do front matter então ele meio que é uma camada que está entre, o harness e entre, o evol ali é o bounding porque eles criaram essa ideia de bounding.
Atômica de trabalho ao invés, de uma, atividade estar dentro de um spec gigantesco e ela não ter um entendimento complexo, do que aquela.
Data Task Pack Agentic
A tarefa como ponto central não a requisição como? Ponto central então é inside out é de dentro para fora, não de fora para dentro.
E aí, olha só, como seria legal, um bounded build por exemplo né então se a gente vier aqui vamos criar, o sketch plane olha só, que legal sketch plane que a gente vai desenvolver.
Ó lembra que a gente criou um contexto lá né então, agora a gente vai vir aqui e a gente vai agora com o contexto injetado a gente, vai chegar aqui e vai falar o seguinte.
Como arquiteto sem executar nada corte dois sketch planes a partir de histórias de spec técnico brief dentro do contrato confirmado plano um transforme modelo medalhão plano um dentro do shell tal tal plano, dois serve api mcp sobre gold apenas enumerando construção cada plano no máximo dez, itens enumerados grave o plano em histórias, de spec quatro plan transformation e plano tal então tá vendo que a gente. Está tendo, que manualmente fazer, isso.
O sinwise que eles vão ter acesso no boot camp é exatamente isso vocês vão começar a interagir com o sistema e eles já têm todas as skills que. Faz isso.
True deliver plan choosing map to task graph two task spec então ele já? Faz toda essa transmutação para você só chama, no sistema e fala cara faz para mim e ele, vai, lá e vai fazer, exatamente isso só que de uma, forma muito mais, numa skill, interpada para fazer, isso ele, vai quebrar essa informação como um todo.
Então qual é, a grande sacada é utilizar isso para acelerar o seu, trabalho absolutamente cara.
Eu gastei muito tempo no task, spec eu gastei muito tempo no sinwise, eu gastei muito tempo no brief spec que agora eu vou dar acesso para vocês, agora e eu vou mostrar o que é o brief spec eu gastei muito tempo no converge e todas essas informações técn.
Alô por. Que você não disponibiliza tudo aqui, para a gente porque não tem tempo necessário para vocês digerirem e entenderem, tudo isso para que, vocês possam usar vocês, precisam entender.
Como vocês estão agora no segundo dia tendo uma claridade. Do, que é pronto de contexto harness bounding e falar caraca legal então no final tudo transmuta para eu cortar o sistema entender o problema, gerar o arquivo e tal cara, vocês tinham essa ideia.
Será que você tinha essa ideia a minha resposta para você é com certeza você tinha essa ideia essa ideia estava estruturada na sua cabeça provavelmente não.
Essa é a grande questão quanto tempo eu gastei fazendo isso muito e isso só aconteceu, justamente pelo tipo de problema, que eu, passei por vários fui carente num projeto que. É assim faço isso e tal qual, o padrão.
Qual é o processo, canônico, para acelerar para eu conseguir trabalhar em sete oito projetos e ter sucesso em todos eles e entregar, em tempos, recordes e fazer. Tudo isso como.
Então essa é a grande questão o bounder será abordado na formação cara dentro da formação você. Tem tudo.
Thank horas de conteúdo tá.
Basically fala com time comercial que aqui, eu quero, falar de coisa louca antes, de eu falar de, coisa louca.
Que a gente vai entrar agora no no no nugget no nugget free para vocês.
Deixa só ir no banheiro me dá por favor, um minuto.
Para fazer. Um bio break aqui porque vocês podem fazer bio, break eu não posso fazer bio, break então deixa, eu fazer, um biobreak eu já volto que aí, vai valer a pena porque agora vocês estão aguardando isso eu vou soltar para vocês o brief spec que é outra coisa no meu, arsenal que eu, mantenho para mim. Mas, vocês vão ter acesso calma aí.
Podemos. Por quê? Allowed.
Do Tespesk do Task Spec.
Não sei se eu consigo disputar aqui.
Beleza. Valeu.
Dentro de tudo isso que foi falado.
Até porque eu acho que isso daí pode se sobressair aos problemas que a gente tem hoje de arquitetura. Por Exemplo Os Nossos Agents.
Talvez eles não consigam enxergar a arquitetura tanto de dados como de sistema completo.
Eu acho que isso pode ajudar em várias soluções que o Lua falou, que teve vários problemas. Eu não sei Se Também Se Você Teve Vários Problemas Os Mesmos Problemas Dele E Tal.
Você pode falar um pouco mais sobre quais problemas?
Foi sanado com tudo isso que a gente está vendo aqui.
O Luan já voltou. Vamos fazer o seguinte. Vamos deixar para o final que ele tem bastante coisa para apresentar. Ainda Era Só Para Matar O Tempo Aqui.
É porque eu quero que você fale um pouquinho do, dge também como que você pensa nessa parte de decomposição porque você, faz também aí vale essa pergunta aí natan para, eu conseguir terminar a gente ir para isso, vamos deixar lá para o final, tá que eu já? Tô acabando aqui.
Então a gente tem aqui a ideia do semi rails and engine então aqui também está fly eu corrijo daqui a pouco, a ideia, é o que a gente já começou a entender é que independentemente.
Dou executor ou de um orquestrador revisor ou, executor você, pode ter algo atômico uma constância entre eles que. São? Exatamente os rails que a gente vai ter e aí com a, parte legal disso, eu queria entregar para vocês algo, que eu particularmente.
Amo, que está dentro do meu coração que, eu criei justamente pelo, problema do multi hardness e que vocês vão ter, acesso agora tá nos minutinhos até eu fechar a live, que é o brief spec.
Então.
Quem quiser.
Se animar aí qual a ideia, tá.
Eh.
Qual a ideia do brief spec tá.
Os seus agentes pensam diferente.
Diferentemente você não deve ler de forma diferente e, eu lembro que quando eu falei isso pro rafa, o rafa, estava passando exatamente pelo mesmo processo que é cara eu uso, hoje vários.
Tipos de hardness né e um dos problemas que eu tenho, é que eles cospem coisas diferentes então eu tenho um overload muito grande e aí eu comecei a literalmente pensar cara como, que eu consigo ter um resultado cuspido interessante pra gente.
Para que eu possa ter uma, carga mental menor e daí obviamente que eu fui olhar em biorecking eu fui olhar em.
Várias fontes.
Para falar cara hoje a gente tem esse blow de conteúdos e tal enfim tal tal tal e daí, eu criei junto com o rafa né o rafa, me ajudou inclusive, a parte de github copilot na verdade na parte do do.
The copilot a gente entregar algo que, é padronizado para, vocês tudo isso que, eu vou mostrar para vocês aqui que vocês vão ver eu vou falar vai estar disponível no, boot camp, tá.
Então o brief spec padroniza o handoff para os agentes e o reasoning dele então você vai instalar ele então basicamente você chega no, codec chega no, cloud e fala cara instala para mim o, brief spec o que ele faz eu instalo ele no nível.
Local para todos os meus, projetos.
Então o que ele faz na verdade ele na verdade pega todas as informações que o agente está cuspindo e ele condensa essa informação num processo de leitura estruturado.
Então ele padroniza, essa leitura para mim. Então como funciona, no final do, dia eu vou receber várias informações do llm.
Ele vai compilar em tempo de, execução essa informação ele vai construir um processo, de output, canônico para mim sempre com a mesma estrutura sempre com o mesmo processo.
E aí o que, é legal não, só isso.
Ele tem vários tipos, de experiência de leitura.
Você tem o outcome, brief.
Que ele, vai te dar status outcome human action, prova gap próximos espaços e eu vou mostrar pra vocês o quanto isso é legal você vai ter o session checkpoint chega uma hora que, ele entende que você falou muita coisa que, aconteceu muita coisa, e ele vai, tentar ele, vai, compilar essas informações para você.
The dentro disso você tem três tipos, de entrega você tem a orientação que ele vai te dar um scan operacional de tudo, que foi falado ele, vai te dar um tet que ele, vai te explicar tudo, que foi feito, ou, ele, vai, transformar isso dentro de, um arquivo de áudio para te dar evidência falada.
Para, você poder ter, a fala do que foi falado ali e aqui tem a estrutura desse cara tem as instalações hoje é disponível no, codecs, cloud code vs code copilot.
Github chat tudo disponível para instalação tá e aí basicamente o que, você vai ter no final. Do, dia você tem isso aqui deixa, eu mostrar.
Deixa, eu mostrar um exemplo.
Then.
Deixa, eu pegar aqui.
Onde, eu tenho eu tenho aqui aqui olha só.
Beleza.
Kick que vocês acham disso.
Isso é o retorno, da leitura que, eu tenho da do anthropic opus v.
Então ele, cuspisse aqui para, mim eu pedi para ele, fazer, eu falei com ele, aqui, cara eu quero fazer, isso ele cuspiu isso aqui pra, mim e aí uma das formas que eu tenho aqui, é o outcome brief que é instalado por, padrão então olha só o que ele faz em vez de eu ficar lendo dessa forma ele faz isso aqui, pra mim.
É a mesma informação e aí como que é aqui status review, outcome.
Okay human. Action.
Tem esse aqui quais são? As provas do que foi falado quais são? Os gaps que foram encontrados quais são? Os próximos, passos e o que é pergunta aberta para você responder então a cada passe que ele, vai interagindo com a llm ele, vai. Fazendo esses autocons briefs para mim. Então eu não preciso, ficar lendo.
Assim.
Depois.
Assim ele simplesmente faz todo projeto olha só o que ele faz outcome brief review.
Outcome, cada passo, deterministico qual é a prova do que eu falei quais são, os gaps que foram encontrados quais são, os próximos passos o que está aberto e assim por diante então agora independentemente da llm que eu converso.
Eu tenho o mesmo tipo de estrutura de resultado final e isso me ajuda justamente a não ter blow de contexto então, eu uso, isso aqui, para todos os meus projetos todos eles tá.
Então isso aqui ajuda muito a você, estruturar. O seu processo, de leitura, e você, vai ganhar de três a cinco x de velocidade. Por quê você vai começar a ler do mesmo jeito, a mesma estrutura.
Go away with status qual é o outcome qual é, o remoction qual é a prova qual é o gap tu imagina que, agora todos os sistemas e todos os resultados que você lê das llms você está vendo nesse contexto o que vai acontecer o que vai acontecer somente vai achar o quê.
Padrão de leitura e isso vai descansar, o seu cérebro para você não ter overload over thinking você não vai ler de um jeito com três, parágrafos depois com dez, depois pequeno depois grande a de psique é de uma, forma, não você vai ter sempre, o mesmo, resultado.
Então eu espero que vocês curtam.
Eu vou deixar disponível enquanto a gente conversa aqui depois eu, tiro.
Trezentos travas de sistemas depois.
Está aqui eles não têm acesso durante os próximos até eu acabar aqui aí. Eu tiro ele faça um download vejam experimentem e sejam felizes.
Então a gente não terminou o bounded né, o bounded aqui, a gente, vai literalmente como desenvol a gente vai criar, o bounding voltando aqui a gente vai criar o bounding deixa, eu só, criar esse bounding.
Para a gente ficar todo mundo alinhado porque a gente criou plano agora a gente vai criar o bounding como developer executivo inteiro um do plano transforma, cria, os dbts model, declarativo esquema tal tal nada de lógica de negócio depois rod, o make dbt, check para fazer, isso.
Então a gente, vai começar a fazer, isso.
Bem e aí obviamente o que a gente, vai fazer no final, é criar uma, skill de hardness para fazer, isso para a gente que, eu vou deixar disponível para vocês que, já está disponível na, verdade no, repositório, que, se chama o quê que, se chama.
Harness scaffolding então o que ele faz na verdade ele entende o seu ambiente e ele monta um harness.
Para poder entregar essa informação, para você.
It documentos passar pelo harness entender o bounding entender todos os componentes o que significa o harness dividir o plano em swim lens ali ter o plano de serving ter o plano de transforming.
Para que amanhã a gente comece o quê pegar, do plano e criar o quê tarefas atômicas daí que vocês vão conhecer amanhã o task spec.
Então o task spec vai ser uma das paradas que vocês vão ter acesso que é, gigante aqui. A gente, precisa de um treinamento, de, horas tá para poder fazer, ele não dá pra fazer, assim vocês vão ter acesso e aí, você já tem ele disponível para codex kim cloud grock.
Vai para, vários outros também e você vai cara aqui, tem enfim você vai morrer aqui, dentro tem hit mac tem validação de chá tem enfim tem muita coisa aqui dentro muita coisa e aí eu vou falar sobre ele amanhã ele divide as tarefas entende o que é pequena média grande cria o contrato.
Esse contrato é assinalado então amanhã vou passar por tudo isso e vocês vão ter, acesso ao task spec que vai ser o quê criamos o plano agora a gente vai criar o quê a atividade atômica de trabalho para poder fazer ele.
Beleza.
Perguntas.
Vamos lá aládio.
Me fala aqui o que. Vocês acharam de hoje me coloca aqui no, chat.
A gente está vendo essa? O que você tem feito ao longo desse ano? Enfim.
E a tua expertise. Quais foram os blocos que você mais teve que você precisou.
Melhorar isso aí, porque a gente sabe que às vezes o Agent não consegue entender muito. Entre as camadas de Arquitetura Tanto De Dados Quanto A Arquitetura Ali De Sistemas.
Então eu queria saber de você aí, do Rafael.
Quais foram? Sei lá, os top cinco. Top dez. Alguma coisa? Vocês têm escrito quando vocês vão escrever um livro? E Quantos Vocês Vão Apresentar No Databrics Lá Enfim.
Que a gente quer ver. Sim.
Aladia essa é uma, pergunta não você deve apresentar. Esse é um tipo de pergunta, inteligente como você, paga noventa e sete e recebe um tipo de resposta que cara é basicamente mensurável.
Eu vou, te falar, quais. São? Os grandes pontos que eu, descobri ao longo desse processo trabalhando doze treze catorze horas todos os dias basicamente.
O primeiro e mais importante coisa para mim é o contexto.
Tá então quando eu falo com texto pensa na questão pensa num repositório. Por exemplo é como ter um repositório muito bem documentado e organizado e aí eu vou te dar a dica de ouro o converge, faz isso e o sim wales também faz na verdade a gente cria adrs.
Então as ed hours funcionam muito bem, porque o conteúdo de uma adr.
Ela é muito bem estruturada nas ações e nas decisões de, arquitetura, que você fez dentro do seu repositório então a ideia é você ter ali um deixa eu mostrar.
Ah não estou compaixão a tela né mas deixa eu mostrar isso foi, um grande divisor de águas para mim então se a gente pegar aqui e a gente vier em docks.
E a gente vier. Por exemplo em adrs eu tenho todas as mais importantes adrs do meu sistema e daí eu tenho o quê eu tenho.
Cloud md que aponta toda, vez para esse cara e aqui, eu tenho toda uma ramificação de documentação então todas as coisas que. São? Documentações dentro do meu, sistema dentro do meu, projeto ele vive dentro da pasta, docs, de uma forma extremamente.
Organizada que faz o ponteramento, então o primeiro ponto extremamente importante.
Segundo, ponto.
Descobrir, em que.
Eu precisava muito processo, que não era, estruturado por, isso que eu, criei o task spec o simwise o converge que vocês vão conhecer também eventualmente justamente para eu, conseguir, padronizar então tente, padronizar o seu processo, isso ajuda muito muito mesmo tem, um framework para fazer, isso, para você.
Terceiro.
Tendo pense muito em spectrum development pensa muito, em tente development, em compilar intenção e quebrar isso em atividades, que são? Tarefas outra coisa que me ajudou muito que o sidmar trouxe aqui.
Ter um século de brain então cara isso pelo menos pra mim na minha perspectiva, mudou o meu ambiente de sei, lá de quarenta pontos para duzentos pontos porque eu tenho tudo em um lugar só e eu posso, utilizar isso como base de informação para criar qualquer coisa.
Na vida prática utilizo muito codex cloud acho que hoje eles estão muito, páreos mas uma lição. Que eu levo é que agora minha preocupação é tentar transformar tudo isso em unidades atômicas, de trabalho e automatizar o que eu já sei.
Yeah a última dica.
Josh, cano, importante é.
Tente pelo menos o que mudou foi, um game changer pra mim tá.
Tenta pegar todos esses, buzz, words essas informações que a gente, recebe todo dia.
Queria, um século, de brain que filtra essas informações cria um documento digerível para você ler no primeiro momento que você, entra no seu, computador que você, faz sua oração sua academia enfim chega no seu computador, seus primeiros quinze, minutos você, lê esse, cara.
Você, digere essa. Informação isso me ajudou extremamente e você tenha formas, de manter o seu repositório, sempre atualizado e aí o rafa falou ontem do ofk enfim que é exatamente essa ideia do padrão do open standard, de documentação e assim por diante que também me ajudou bastante.
Eu diria que de tudo, que eu fiz cara.
Hoje documentação e mantém isso atualizada e constante, tem um processo, para isso uma das coisas, que mais me ajudaram, a entregar e estipar feature com muita qualidade.
Então acho que esses, pontos rafa o que você tem, aí você tem, muita coisa, também para, compartilhar.
Eu vou estender muito. Não, porque na verdade, isso aqui é uma conversa longa, né? Eu e o Luan, a Gente Conversa Muito Sobre Isso Acaba Que No Final Das Contas A Gente Sempre Trabalha Em Paralelo.
No final das contas, chegamos sempre ajustado, muito, muito parecidos em relação a tudo.
Hoje eu tenho trabalhado. Além de tudo isso que o Lance falou. Eu tenho trabalhado muito no sentido de entender Que Os Agentes Já Estão Muito Inteligentes Os Harness Estão Muito Bons.
Então a grande ideia, na minha opinião, é desenvolver um método onde eu saia do processo. Eu consiga falar para O Agente O Que Eu, Quero.
Ele é o desenvolvedor. Ele que decide. Então, a partir do momento.
Passa a demanda para ele. Você fala. A sua intenção define o que você quer dar o meio de trabalho Para Ele Ele Vai Gerar A Documentação Do Seu Projeto.
Eu estou trabalhando muito nessa frente. Então ele gera o conhecimento que os próximas interações do agente vão fazer em Cima Do Sistema Então é Assim Que Eu Tenho Trabalhado Ultrapassar.
Então o agente. Ele desenvolve. Ele documenta o que ele aprendeu. Documenta os problemas, documenta quais foram os que ele decidiu fazer.
E as próximas gerações, eles passam por cima desse processo de aprendizado para conseguir se auto melhorar. Então o meu Projeto De Look Agent Trabalha Dessa Forma.
Ele é muito parecido com converge. Mas tanto o Dge, o Delivery Graphic como o ilum. Eles têm essa ideia de self learning.
Gente trabalhar independente de qual seja o carnes e qual independente de qual seja o modelo.
Então você chega a ser na verdade um Pm, né? Mas aí você tem que saber os fundamentos. Bem, para que você possa.
Falar. Pô isso aqui está errado. Isso aqui está. Certo.
Então há algo que o Luan sempre fala, né? Pô fundamentos, fundamentos, fundamentos. Cada vez mais entra na parte de Engenharia E Arquitetura De Sistemas.
Exatamente.
Beleza. Muito obrigado.
Valeu!
André opa desculpa, natan aí, daqui a pouco, eu passo, para vocês fica tranquilo então não vai falar.
Pode falar natália.
É bem nessa linha do que o alad falou pensando que você já tem toda essa estrutura montada boa parte do trabalho, é justamente nesse, processo de compilar, a intenção é isso porque você, estava comentando aí, que.
Depois você está trabalhando há oito meses, então se você tem, todas essas essa, estrutura você consegue chegar até na atividade. Atômica e você tem toda uma, infraestrutura mesmo que vai permitir que.
A tarefa chegue no outro lado, tonta, não importa qual o caminho eh o trabalho, realmente no estádio que você está, é de compilar a intenção e aí, o quanto mais o rápido você consegue fazer, isso é meio que vai definir quanto, tempo você vai, fazer.
Projeto.
A última parte a intenção é o que mais, demora tempo então ela vai ser decisiva obviamente mas a grande questão são? Duas primeiro compilando intenção.
E, depois faz algo como o rafa falou porque qual, o problema que a gente vai passar que o rafa, está se adiantando já o rafa já está fazendo, eu diria, que eu estou criando uma fábrica de software o rafa, tem quantos agentes você tem rafa geralmente trabalhando nessa solução que você, faz.
Ativos em produção.
Hoje nós estamos. Estamos com vinte e três agentes.
Então eu não tenho esse não esse nível de. Granularidade tocando várias coisas, porque os agentes lá no projeto. Do rafa ele toca várias coisas diferentes várias, características então ele já está se adiantando para um problema que vai existir no mercado que poucas pessoas que estão na, empresas de, grande porte estão falando.
Que é exatamente a ideia do ilum que é a ideia de você deixar o agente executar e ele começar a, falar cara fiz, isso fiz, aquilo enfim e isso vai gerando uma, base de conhecimento para que todo, mundo entre, lá dentro e comece, a trabalhar, e o rafa vai conseguir falar isso muito. Melhor do, que eu mas isso já? É um problema que vai acontecer então.
Três coisas que eu, vejo compilar a intenção.
Construir. A fábrica e ter garantia que você não tem o quê derailing que não saia dos objetivos e o ilum, resolve exatamente esse processo, rafa aí, é mais ou, menos por aí.
Exatamente.
Então acho que esses três grandes tópicos hoje primeiro compilar, a intenção segundo construir. A fábrica se tirando do loop fazendo ela ficar autônoma cada vez mais e terceiro depois dando essa informação de feedback loop ou essa informação para ele, que ele realmente está seguindo o caminho que esse é o caminho que ele tem que seguir que. É isso que ele tem que fazer está certo, assim tá certo assado e meio que continuar fazendo com que ele permaneça ali no trilho dele.
André.
Oh você está usando o obsidian para.
What's, a sequence, brain o okf você já está aplicando no seu dia a dia como que está essa parte aí.
Compartilhamento do seu segundo salário com a ele am.
Comigo eu utilizo três camadas eu utilizo diversos plugins mcps aí eu utilizo codecs e aí do, codecs eu escrevo no second brain o meu second brain constante ativo aí ele tem duas formas, o nixon que eu chamo ele ele tem a parte ativa e a parte reativa.
A parte que ele vai só receber e a parte reativa que ele vai reagir a certos tipos de cláusulas e informações que eu uso e agora eu estou tentando implementar, o fk nesse meu projeto de, tres dois milhões de linhas, eu ainda não. Implementei ele então eu ainda não.
Ainda está organizando.
Eu ainda não posso, falar eu ainda estou organizando mas o plano é esse acho que você viu até uma thread que está, ali no meu, super engineering a ideia, é transformar exatamente isso num processo aqui.
Depois eu vou compartilhar uma coisa que eu descobri recente, o pessoal do maranhão está usando o obsidium e, criando task para poder criar as minutas dos processos para julgamento.
Eu fiquei assim impressionado com a forma com que eles estão trabalhando semelhante ao que você. Faz mas ele tem o respaldo do back end do obsidia.
Caraca que.
Eu achei interessante que você tem aquela aquele retorno, visual que você consegue.
A parte humana né.
É por, isso que eu fiquei curioso de, repente você já tinha? Alguma coisa aí já adiantada.
No no i não estou nesse nível ainda não não de implementar e falar, pô foi implementado e está funcionando ainda não.
Mas a gente chega lá.
João?
Gente, aí a gente acaba as perguntas tá acaba no emerson.
Boa noite, eu queria perguntar um pouco, nessa linha de desafio se você enfrentou alguma coisa relacionada a trabalhar com equipes.
Grandes você está aí, trabalhando em ontologia por, exemplo como é que você protege o seu, sistema de talvez outros engenheiros não poluírem esse seu contexto que, está tão bem refinado como é que, você distribui isso a nível tímido você já fez isso.
Trabalho nesse code base tem muita coisa no final das coisas tem que convergir para um sistema que a gente, já fala na sexta feira um processo de code review alguma coisa muito mais, madura um gatekeeper realmente né para que ele possa satisfazer todas essas camadas e portões antes de, você comentar alguma coisa.
Então assim problema nenhum disso ser aberto para todo mundo. Do, time é as long as enquanto eles consigam, conformar no que. É estabelecido, no que você diz o que, é estabelecido para. Um bom por requests ou, para um bom conceito, então, tudo isso que, você tem na sua, cabeça que, talvez seja fácil para você, ou que, você entenda, que seja qualidade.
Projeto que você esteja, a ideia, é você compilar tirar isso da sua, cabeça e, criar portões validações e processos para que na hora em que alguém faça alguma coisa, ele passe por todos esses caras até ter a qualidade necessária, para entrar no seu sistema.
Então na verdade é só, pensar em como você vai distribuir essas qualidades então exemplo.
Vou dar, um exemplo para você aqui.
Eu tenho que, traduzir, um arquivo de teskl para python beleza existem várias, formas de fazer. Isso se o deep, olhar ele, vai transformar de uma forma se o cláudio olhar vai transformar de outra e, assim por diante beleza eu posso, pedir para o meu, time fazer, isso e como, está lá no repositório, ou eu posso, falar para, eles o seguinte. Olha.
Quando. Seu agente for comentar quando, você quiser, trabalhar nesse codebase você tem, que ter uma pasta spec desse spec você tem que gerar um prd desse, prd você tem, que gerar as. Atividades atômicas no task spec do task, spec ele, tem que fazer, essa atividade dessa atividade ele tem que bater esses critérios desses critério ele tem que fazer. Isso aí, quando chegar aqui você, vai rodar essa cli que vai testar aí depois você, vai passar beleza aí você vai submeter lá numa branch.
Aí. Vai rodar um ci que vai verificar se isso que você, fez está seguindo os padrões de, arquitetura. Do que, realmente é o python então você vai criar todo, esse processo, e aí, vai da sua, cabeça tirar isso e colocar, isso dentro.
De processos e games.
Tovi tavil.
Totally.
Boa noite pessoal a minha dúvida é a seguinte eu e a maioria, acho que sofre com legados por aí, que. Não tem documentação daí pensando na nova fase de a gente. Tá fazendo documentação fazendo que tem que ser feito.
Mas para a gente não ser o futuro pessoal que não, faz a documentação como que a gente convence, o pessoal que é necessário ter a documentação se a vibe da maioria das empresas está, de economizar token ao máximo e tipo documentação necessária foco no que é importante.
Rapaz é uma, pergunta difícil porque meio que.
Destroi ao propósito, da documentação né. Sendo que uma das coisas que a l, faz muito bem na minha, humilde, opinião, é, documentação né acho que assim se eu, fosse elencar quais são, as melhores coisas que ela faz eu provavelmente elencaria.
Documentação então.
No portf.
Mas. Vocês vocês são? Mais tem mais expertise vocês acham que a documentação gasta tanto token assim quanto o código ou não.
Gasta, gasta muito token ao conteúdo como um todo mas. Assim é uma coisa que não é extremamente complexa de fazer então o que eu estou querendo, dizer é o seguinte, pô será que você precisa utilizar um opus para fazer, documentação.
Será que você precisa de um, feibo eu já vi a galera, meter um, feible, para fazer, documentação pô será que um, sonnet não faz isso vai ser pô será que, um modelo, open source será que, não vale se você tem uma, infraestrutura por exemplo como eu sei que você pode ter talvez.
Okay.
Será que não vale a pena ter um modelo, open source, ali por exemplo para fazer, documentação então meio que pensar nessas sombras eu só, acho que não tem como viver sem documentação.
Obrigado.
Caroline.
Boa noite eu acho que, eu queria endereçar, um pouco, mais para o rafa que eu fiquei curiosa né, eu tenho vinte e três agentes de produção aí como que começou isso porque.
Eh hoje eu trabalho só com o copality eu sei que na minha empresa a gente, tem a opção de usar o codecs e o pessoal aqui do chat falou que é melhor eu migrar para o codecs vou pedir minha licença amanhã, já quando eu começar a trabalhar para mudar e aí eu queria começar.
A, trabalhar com, agentes porque lá tem, esse problema que eu falei de, passar uma refaturação do etr e legado para refaturado também tem umas outras transcrições lá de mudança de linguagem, para fazer, no meu trabalho, e eu quero poder por isso que eu até entrei nessa semana aqui.
Eu quero, poder trabalhar melhor com as ias que a gente, tem lá disponível, a minha empresa está numa fase assim vamos gastar dinheiro e vamos testar então eu quero, surfar essa onda porque eu sei que uma hora a torneirinha, do dinheiro vai fechar dos, tokens.
Então eu quero poder usar de uma? Forma mais produtiva aí para começar a trabalhar com esses agentes vocês criam um repositório, à parte como é que vocês trabalham com isso nas ferramentas que, vocês têm.
é na verdade, o que acontece? Esse sistema específico que o Luan falou.
E é um sistema bastante complexo. Ele é muito grande. Hoje a gente trabalha em torno de dois. Virgula, cinto, mil tabelas.
Okay.
Então é uma quantidade de dados bem massiva. Bem grande. Então, assim cada agente tem uma função específica dentro de um Workflow que demanda automação. Então é por isso que ele tem vinte e três agentes. Então cada agente faz um pedaço da tarefa e tem.
Alega isso para um próximo agente ou para o agente seguinte ou anterior. E essa informação é reprocessada até que Ela Chegue Ao Final E Entregue O Resultado Final Para O Usuário Por Isso Que São Vinte E Três Agentes.
O projeto foi desenvolvido.
Aí. Voltando um pouco para o seu caso, ele foi desenvolvido com o Copalit.
E aí o modelo. A gente tem a opção de escolher qualquer modelo, na verdade, e uso ilimitado. Mas a Restrição é Que O Harness Seja O Copalid.
Então é igual a gente conversou aqui na aula. Não existe limitação hoje para o que você consegue fazer.
Mostrou. Ele vai te dar uma estrutura de como você vai trabalhar com o Copale. Como você vai trabalhar com O Codecs Como Você Vai Trabalhar Com O Cloud Code.
Tendo essa estrutura, e sabendo o que você está fazendo, essa estrutura vai montar um contexto. Bom, esse contexto. Bom, Ele Vai Gerar Resultados Bons Então A Ideia Aqui é Exatamente Essa é Como Você Usar Esses Produtos.
Gente costuma falar muito. Que existem dois tipos de engenheiros hoje. Tem um engenheiro que usa Iá, que é o Pessoal Que Desenvolve Utilizando Cloud Codecode Utilizando Copilot E Por Aí Vai.
Tem o engenheiro de A, que é o cara que entrega Iá. Então o meu caso é, eu entrego produto De A Então Eu Já Tenho Produtos De Produção.
Utilizam Ia para entregar resultado para o cliente.
Tem que ver qual é o seu caso. Porque os dois casos, eles são válidos. Só que é. São categorias de uso diferente.
Mas esses agentes você manteria, no mesmo record desse projeto ou você manteria uma parte.
é aí.
A questão do, armazenamento, deles.
Então, o que acontece aí? A gente entra numa esfera chamada Agentsops.
Que é onde você faz gerenciamento e questionamento de modelos e agentes. Então eu tenho tudo isso dentro do projeto. Então Eu Tenho Um Determinado Agente Que Faz Tem Uma Determinada Função.
Quando tem uma alteração de um modelo, eu faço todo esse direcionamento. Então tem todo um controle em cima disso. Eu Não Posso Chegar Lá Porque às Vezes Você Tem Um Prompt Ali, Com.
Quatro, cinco zero linhas que vocês botam uma vírgula, e isso muda o formato de atenção do modelo. E ele Acaba Quebrando Aquela Intenção Específica Que O Modelo Deveria.
Retornar. Então tem todo um controle feito em cima disso. Então, sim, os agentes são versionados. Eles ficam dentro do Mesmo Repositório Do Projeto Mas Tem Toda Uma Estrutura De.
Ops em cima dos agentes.
Nada.
Certo obrigada.
Emerson.
Boa noite, Luan. Boa noite.
Me tira uma dúvida assim, dentro desse processo de agentes.
A gente, eh? O projeto. Ele vai tendo evoluções e. E vai tendo melhorias e novas testes e assim por diante.
Com isso. A documentação, ou até mesmo o conteúdo da próprio projeto vai criando vários documentos de melhoria de.
Evolução do mesmo. Como que com esses agentes ao término.
Dessas evoluções, conseguiremos colocar uma documentação limpa e clara para.
Deixar isso bem explícito para as próximas tarefas.
Porque o agente tem a mania de gerar muita documentação.
Explicativa dentro do processo. Como que eu posso deixar isso limpo quando terminar toda a tarefa.
Ah, legal.
Dá uma olhada nisso, aqui esse link aí vai te responder isso é exatamente o que a gente, estava falando da ideia. Do, ufk que, é um padrão de open knowledge format que, a google trouxe que acho que ajuda bastante isso e eu acho que é uma das coisas que eu estava procurando há muito tempo mas eu.
Não tinha uma forma para isso acho que, o rafa até tinha começado a, trabalhar com, isso antes mesmo, disso de, se existir.
Mas. Isso é que eu acho que resolve bastante como, eu faço hoje sem o okf.
Eu crio um ci.
Então pô vamos supor a gente escreveu sei lá pão de queijo enfim fez uma nova branch escreveu lá enfim.
Quando ele, comita isso lá quando ele, faz a intenção de, comitar para, mim eu rodo um ci que chama o cloud code e ele vai lá e pega essa documentação dele e organiza inteira na estrutura que eu quero então toda. Vez eu garanto, que qualquer coisa que seja, puxada para mim está organizada. Do, jeito que eu quero.
There is e, aí gente bom demais.
Curtir foi ótimo, amanhã a gente vai começar a falar de execução a gente vai navegar no task spec vai entender como compilar aquilo quebrar.
Trabalhar utilizar multihanners vocês vão ver amanhã um deep psique um kimi um cloud code um opus um terra um sol e um luna executarem tarefas iguais com o mesmo outcome no final olha, que loucura vocês vão entender literalmente a execução, o nível granular.
A gente vai entrar na parte de tarefas beleza então no atraso amanhã, não perde amanhã, tem outro nugget eu vou soltar aqui o task, spec tá inclusive muito obrigado por, lembrar luan estou transformando meu brief spec de novo, em.
Priv.